hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
i'm just checking in on you
um
seeing how you're doing seeing how your
week's going getting adjusted trying to
get comfortable here on the bed
trying to knock the podcast out before i
take the kids to school
for god's sakes by the way by the way oh
billy [ __ ] tits
[ __ ] move down a notch on his belt in
the right direction
okay
i am on my journey this is my journey
this is something that i need to
encounter
i have to figure out why i was eating
those ice cream sandwiches every night
depression
um
yeah i'm going from billy [ __ ] tits to
uh bill bulimia bill bulimic
hi this is uh mr bulimic how are you
is that is that bulimia or is that the
other one
bulimia is the one where you get to
enjoy the meal before you give it back
is that what it is i don't know
anorexia is when you just don't eat
that's what it is
i don't know what it is but i'm sure
i'm sure i'm messing it up no believe me
yeah
whatever you know what i mean it's like
trying to [ __ ] remember
you know lefty loosey righty tighty and
then you're like unscrewing a light bulb
above your head and you're like wait did
the same rules apply when i'm looking
down over but now i'm like above it now
but i'm under it it's like i'm hovering
over it but i'm under it
you know that's like my [ __ ] with like
which which which is the front of the
stage which is the back of this of i'm
sorry of a stove
you know to me
the back of the stove
is is by the wall
and the front of the stove
i i don't i always have it i always have
it wrong now i don't even remember
that is the bats is the way it is
but for me i was always standing behind
it
for some reason so the back of the stove
to me was the burner closer to me and
then the front is whatever see people
this is why i became a comedian
this is why i never made it in carpentry
i tried to do carpentry i lasted [ __ ]
eight days i was just like i do not have
the gift
i have the brains i could sit here all
[ __ ] you know years of my life
and become
and work my way up to being a mediocre
carpenter
god knows that's what people want huh
they want a carpenter that does an okay
job i'll tell you right now who cannot
do an okay job this sunday
joe burrow with the bengals
or matthew stafford
from the lions and now with the rams
that's amazing can you imagine if the
rams win it and matthew stafford after
all of those years
being in that dysfunctional abusive
relationship
that is being the quarterback of the
detroit lions
i mean who's kidding who that is a how
many ex-boyfriends
did that [ __ ] [ __ ] of a team leave
laying on the side of the road
i'm trying to think of all
greg landry eric hipple all the way
through joey harrington
matthew stafford has been like
he was the general he's probably the
best lions quarterback they've had
since uh what's his face there
i got his book right here heart of a
lion bobby lane
bobby lane yeah
i i would say that let me look this [ __ ]
up
let me look this [ __ ] up
the history of lions quarterbacks okay
and i'm gonna tell you right now there's
going to be a lot
of [ __ ] real estate agents
whatever people do after your the
quarterback
of the [ __ ] detroit lions
um
now i'm
wondering
you know as a lions fan you got to be
rooting for matthew stafford because he
did put the time in but then also
you kind of got to be rooting against
him because it's just like
you know
qb history um
if he wins it the very next year it's
gonna kind of confirm
you know it's gonna kind of confirm what
you always thought that there's just
something wrong
with your franchise all right since the
great days
of bobby lane 1950 51
all the way through 57 and then they
joined the steelers i believe
we're gonna get into my okay greg landry
greg landry you made it from 71 to 74.
and joe reed i guess he was all of a
sudden third string they blamed him and
then they like we're just [ __ ] with
you brought him back 76-77 gary
danielson
all right those years couple years eric
hipple gary danielson back and forth no
one wanted to say it was the lion's
fault the switch that was right through
86. there was a guy chuck long
they had a guy rusty
give rusty a shot rusty hilger
and then oh god poor rodney pete
coming out of usc
da da da da
he was there from 89 90 91 92 93 the
arsenio hall show years i believe no he
was a little bit up there
the tonight show
with johnny carson was 92.
but i think garcinia was still around
cindy was still around
those years
the running gun of the bills losing
every year
or senior hall
coming after johnny carson just putting
this all in prest historical perspective
with uh
cape fear i think was a big movie back
then
natural board history scott mitchell
then 94 to [ __ ] 97.
charlie batch
sounds like yak charlie yak ty detmer
was in there too
honorable mention
uh joey harrington 2002 2003 2004 2005
good day sir
jeff garcia backup somehow he got out of
there and went to san francisco john
kittner
lasted two years
dan
orlovsky
and then in 2009 along came a man
named matthew stafford who has had he
had the longest tenure
as a quarterback he started in two for
the alliance 2009 2010 sean hill
got the starting job and matthew
stafford was back up he played then
stafford comes back 2011 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19
20.
10
straight
seasons
he must own every [ __ ] record
bobby lane was wait bobby 50 51 51 was
eight seasons
no 50 one two three four five six
seven now that is eight seasons
wow
i don't know
matthew stafford is he going to do it on
sunday i'll tell you right now the key
to the game's going to be that offensive
line can they protect joe burrow against
the the down four the [ __ ] ramps
what do you guys think
do you think the golden boy joe burrow
comes in
and rightfully claims what should have
been the bengals rather than the 49ers
all throughout the uh all throughout the
80s that should have been bill walsh on
their sideline coaching
but the great paul brown
the only mistake he made turned out to
be the biggest mistake ever for those
cincinnati bengals he thought bill walsh
did not
have the mental stability to be a head
coach in the nfl and he badmouthed him
around the league and he let him go
well bill just left it was nothing else
he could do
and he worked his way back into a head
coaching job with the san francisco
49ers
and he applied that offense that he came
up with with the cincinnati bengals the
what became known as the west coast
offense was actually created in
cincinnati i know i've said this before
but people don't listen every week but
now you know
the rest of the story and how ironic
that two of their four super bowl
victories
of the 49ers in the 1980s the team of
the 80s were against
those cincinnati bengals
i got a roof for the bengals
i like the ramps this one this is one of
these super bowls you're just gonna be
happy for people
you know i'll be happy for matthew
stafford i won't be happy for la fans
they're just uh they're just not
informed enough
they really are like i don't i don't
know what it is i don't know why it is
so hard to find
an informed los angeles fan i don't know
why it's great when you do
old school laker fans from back at the
forum
people who grew up watching the dodgers
hating the yankees in the late 70s i
love meeting la fans like that but it is
just so [ __ ] rare
i don't know bill maybe it's the company
you keep maybe it is
maybe it is i don't know
um
i don't know
it's just
if you critique their team they just go
hater
hater it just never gets into a good
sports debate
your team are [ __ ]
it's like
all right i guess that's what it is okay
um anyway and the funny thing is what is
funny bill has anything been funny so
far in this podcast did you [ __ ] list
every goddamn jerk off that played
quarterback for the rams for the last 50
years
hey i'm into that [ __ ]
if you didn't listen to this podcast
would you ever know about marlon briscoe
huh
you want to talk about the modern day
[ __ ] nfl a guy who would have changed
the game if they let him
marlon briscoe with the denver broncos
first starting black quarterback in the
nfl and you look at it you're seeing
randall cunningham and all of these
other guys [ __ ] 20 something years
later you're seeing him play in that
style right then and there you see them
be successful and what did they do they
drafted a white guy
it made marlon briscoe a wide receiver
another
this is this is like a segment that i'm
gonna make or maybe i mean you guys
probably know more about this [ __ ] than
i do this segment is called horrific
fuck-ups
[Music]
in the nfl
um i'll start with two the uh uh the
denver broncos letting turning marlon
briscoe into a wide receiver and
shipping him off to buffalo rather than
keeping him as quarterback of the denver
broncos number two
two two two
the cincinnati bengals passing over the
great bill walsh
who had already invented the west coast
what would become known as the west
coast offense because of bill parcells
coining it in 1985 when his giants beat
the 49ers in the playoffs and he said
what do you think of that west coast
offense now
um
thus giving credit
that that offense was created in san
francisco and i guarantee you there's a
bunch of 49er fans you know
walking around with their winter jackets
on in january because of that weird
weather up there i mean sorry in july
let me tell you that time i took a
vacation
to san francisco in the summertime
like 20 years ago
with my girlfriend at the time and we
both wore like summer clothes
and we you know we landed in oakland
because it was cheaper and we took the
bart over
and it was like the summer and we were
all excited this is going to be great
san francisco we're going to have a
great time and we got it we took the
bart to the subway
and we came up out of the ground and
the only thing
more shocking than how [ __ ] cold it
was
was the sheer amount of homeless people
and the level
of homeless that they had just the way
they looked
like the they look like 49ers they look
like miners
like boxcar willy looking for like
jump on a rail car like [ __ ] beards
and
it looked like you were watching a bad
hollywood movie and they needed like a
homeless guy and they just like overly
make the person homeless
um
and we froze our asses off and we
couldn't figure out what the [ __ ]
deal was
so we immediately go out and buy a bunch
of [ __ ] you know sweatshirts that say
san francisco on them you know with the
local [ __ ] whatever
and then we went inland at one point to
go to like magic mountain or something
like that some amusement park and then
all of a sudden it was hot as balls
the second we got in there
bill does this story have an ending not
really does it have a point yeah they
got weird weather out there anyway
um
horrific fuck-ups
in sports
i can tell you can just i can tell you
right now the the celtics when we had
red aura back where we're always on the
the good end of that
you know
the robert parish trade
whatever the [ __ ] we did to get kevin
mchale and larry bird's rights we always
seem to come out on top
with moves like that i mean dallas
cowboys i mean i mean the minnesota
vikings it's obviously the herschel
walker trade
you know that was one of the great
[ __ ]
i can't even say it was great i just
feel like jimmy johnson the entire time
was like there's no way they're gonna
sign this deal
there's no way let me make sure i get
this [ __ ] deal right
what happened with the with the herschel
walker trade
was the minnesota vikings agreed
to give as far as i remember they were
they agreed to give all like these just
[ __ ]
um
regular guys up like 10 regular guys up
for herschel walker
so they thought that they were getting a
steal
but there was something in there that if
if
if jimmy cut those cut any of the
players in the trade
he would get draft picks from the
vikings so the second they signed it he
goes you know i'm gonna cut all those
players they're like you wouldn't
[ __ ] do that and they were like yeah
and he took all the vikings draft picks
and had all the cowboys and that's how
they built here we go herschel walker
trade was the largest the largest player
trade in the history of the national
football league the deal on october 12
1989 centered centered on sending
running back herschel walker from the
dallas cowboys to the minnesota vikings
including walker in a transit
transaction involving the san diego
chargers the trade involved 18 players
in draft picks at the time of the deal
the cowboys were one of the worst teams
in the league the team finished the 1989
season with its worst post
post merger record of one in 15 trading
away their best player while the vikings
believed that walker was the missing
piece they needed to make a super bowl
run thus minnesota originally felt that
they got the better end of the deal the
cowboys used the draft picks acquired in
this trade to get players they needed to
help them win three super bowls
meanwhile the vikings did not make a
super bowl appearance with walker
um they kind of glossed over it here
okay the vikings immediately assumed
they got the better not knowing at the
time that head coach jimmy johnson was
interested only in the draft picked and
not the players at a press conference
after the trade johnson's bragged that
he created he committed oh he bragged
right after he committed the great train
robbery but was criticized by various
sports writers such as randy galloway of
the dallas morning news johnson waved
stewart in november of 1989 then told
coaches to not start solomon howard or
holt signaling to the rest of the league
his intention to claim the draft picks
viking general manager mike lin
eventually made another deal letting the
cowboys keep the three players
and all the conditional picks wait a
second
all right in the original proposal
dallas agreed to give herschel walker
and three draft picks to minnesota
in exchange the cowboys would get from
the vikings five players three draft
picks and conditional picks attached to
each of those five players should they
be cut by the dallas cowboys before
february 1990 so that's what he did
he got three draft picks and five
players he cut those five players so he
got eight draft picks plus all the picks
that the cowboys had
uh one of those players
that minnesota agreed to send to dallas
darren nelson refused to report to the
cowboys dallas then agreed to trade
nelson to the san diego charger for
their fifth round pick in 1990 which the
cowboy promptly sent to the vikings in
total this revised trade involved 18
players and draft picks
uh
okay so the cowboys got linebacker jesse
salman linebacker david howard isaac
holt alex stewart
uh a first round pick in 1990 second
round pick in 1990 sixth round pick 1990
minnesota's first round pick in 91
minnesota's second round pick in 91
minnesota's first round pick in 92
second round pick in 92 minnesota's
third round pick in 92.
and all of those last ones
okay the first round pick in 91
condition on cutting solomon which he
did second round conditional on cutting
howard which he did condit
first round pick in 92 conditional and
cutting hold he did you get the picture
um condition met by trading nelson and
condition cutting stewart so he just cut
all of them and he got [ __ ] eight
[ __ ] draft picks plus all the draft
picks they had from being
you know one of the shittier teams in
the league and what did he do with those
draft picks i think uh
players selected
let's see
pick acquired by minnesota dallas's
third round pick and they just picked
all bums
end result uh three super bowl wins
here's the end result what they got they
got emmett smith
russell maryland
clayton holmes kevin smith darren
woodson
well i thought they got more guys than
that
i mean well russell maryland was a guy
and i heard of that guy and darren
woodson
emmett smith that was a huge one
um
all right whatever all i know is that
they ended up winning [ __ ] three
super bowls in four years and the
vikings have yet to win a super bowl
and that concludes
then we'll follow up great fuck-ups and
sports
with great fuck-ups in your own life
all right we'll keep the great fuck-ups
in your own life
light
okay so they're not too depressing
all right you want to hear about the one
and only [ __ ] flight i ever missed in
my stand-up career
um
i had an early flight i didn't get
enough sleep because i was doing spots
the night before and i went to lax the
old lax when the carpet was all gray and
all that [ __ ] before they
gussied it up here for the [ __ ]
olympics for the second time a lot of
people don't realize that that the first
time
they um
you know
before the 84 olympics they just had
that horseshoe design on the bottom
it was only one level and that was the
airport and they're like holy [ __ ] we're
going to host the olympics we need to
double the size of this now did they
correct the horror
the outdated horror of of that design
where everybody just has to go in
and there's nothing you can do
they kind of did because they created
shortcuts in between
but they just doubled down on that
horseshoe design and then just added
another layer on top of it
uh it's like if you built a split entry
on top of a split entry
so anyway
um i went down to the airport i was so
[ __ ] tired i read
my seating assignment as my gate
and i went
to the gate that was the same as my
seating assignment and i went there and
there was nobody there and i always got
there early because i was
afraid of um
missing my flight
and uh i was sleepy and i sort of nodded
off and then i woke up and it was like
literally five minutes or ten minutes
before boarding and not only was there
nobody yet there was just nobody at the
gate and i finally looked and i was like
oh [ __ ] it was on the whole other side
of the airport and i just ran like a
lunatic
and i had the ugliest luggage i remember
i deliberately picked the ugliest
luggage
so it was easy for me to spot when it
came down the [ __ ]
the baggage carousel and i was running
with that [ __ ] hunk of [ __ ]
and i remember getting to the gate and i
just see the lady and she's just like
shaking her head no and i'm like i did
oh i did was sitting inside went through
okay she's like yeah no
no it's too late we already closed the
door but the [ __ ] plane is still
there there's a hallway connected to the
plane
just open two doors
i'm i'm i'm sorry sir i'm i'm sorry
there's nothing we can do
once the door is closed the door cannot
be reopened
and then i i was like you know i was
living on the west coast and my gig
was on central time so i was already
losing time and i also had to drive to
the [ __ ] gig
so
rather than having plenty of time to get
to the gig i ended up getting on a
flight that gave me just enough time if
i drove like 85 [ __ ] miles an hour
for whatever car i got at national
rental car i always got the dodge neon
for whatever reason and it always seemed
to be
in plum crazy purple
um
and i remember getting in the car and
just driving like a [ __ ]
lunatic
didn't even check into the hotel
drove straight to the gig got out of the
car
walked in they're like oh we were
getting worried
and i'm like yeah what's the deal and
then just [ __ ] walking out on stage
just after all of that [ __ ] hey how
you doing how's it going all right nice
to be here in duluth
or whatever the [ __ ] i was
and i did the gig and i somehow uh
i got through it but there you go that's
great fuck-ups
in my life i know i have great
fuck-ups greater fuck-ups than that
i don't know
i've still i've talked about all of them
in [ __ ] therapy maybe that's a bad
idea maybe you want to use this
this podcast is therapy
i have no idea
um you know my laugh was watching
um
i gotta take my kids to school i'm gonna
take a break here for a second my wife
was watching a documentary
on that that white woman who was
pretending to be black
and um
[Music]
i might get around for the last 10
minutes to talk about that because i
just kept teasing her
going you know what question they're not
asking in all of this document they're
asking all of the obvious questions
but i was like nia
how
did this white woman how did you guys
allow this white woman
to become head
of the naacp chapter in spokane
washington how does that happen
and there was all these people like
after the fact you know when there's
like a big upset in sports and then
everybody actually oh you know i had a
feeling all these people are going like
yeah i knew there was something
i was i was thinking this just looks
like a white woman with braids everybody
was saying i was kind of thinking that
[ __ ] i just think
that that part of the country people are
just really polite when they're not
having a clan meeting or whatever
generally speaking there's a certain
level of politeness to that
area well i just don't think that that
would happen in in
different cities
i think someone would just ask you're
like uh what is your [ __ ] deal
but anyway my wife was watching it
and i was trying to go to sleep it was
just [ __ ]
um it was driving me nuts because no one
would just they kept
arguing with her
and it's just like you you got to look
at this person like she's a crazy person
at a bus stop
i was i was i just felt bad for her kids
maybe it's not a good topic whatever i
just felt bad for her kids because she
just kept like
kept saying [ __ ] like i'm
unapologetically black it was just like
oh my god
and like her kids were like really cool
but they had this sort of
low energy monotone way of talking and
as i was watching more and more of it i
was like i think this is like depression
there's like a low level of depression
and then they can't break away from her
because she's like posting pictures of
them and saying where they're trying to
go to college and it's just
like listen
can you stop having them
pay the price for your sins
um
i don't you know how human beings are
human beings will actually get upset at
her kids
instead of it the person that did it
which is her which is really uh
i don't know this podcast was fun until
i brought that up i will uh
i'll see if i can get uh the lovely knee
on here i gotta drive the kids to school
here so i'll be right back all right you
guys sit tight and with the magic of
editing
i'll be right back in like half a second
all right
all right i'm back before we get into uh
a little conversating there
with my lovely wife i got a little read
here um simply safe everybody
today's episode is brought to you by
simply safe home security
have you ever wanted to know what's
happening at your home when you're not
there i'm a big fan of the new wireless
outdoor camera from simply safe that's
great they don't have to drill into your
house uh let's just see what's happening
see what's happening outside right from
your phone and alerts you when anyone
approaches so you always know who's
there simply says has everything you
need to keep your home safe from entry
and motion sensors to indoor and outdoor
cameras simply say simply safe is
monitored 24 7 by professionally
professionals ready to dispatch police
firefighters or emts to your home
simply safe is less than one dollar a
day and you can set it up around up in
around 30 minutes there are no long-term
contracts or commitments you can
customize the perfect system for your
home in just a few minutes at simply
safe s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive
monitor
monitoring
interactive monitoring
all right it's a new word in my english
language go to
simplysafe.comburr that's it
all right and with that look who it is
everybody walking around the room
look who it is
it's the lovely oh you gotta watch it's
the elegant yes nia renee keep going
hill you gotta watch uh
housewives of jersey with me just
because you gotta see
the jerseyness
of the husbands in there i just feel
like you'll fight because you've seen a
couple of episodes of it i love new
jersey and so yes
i don't know this last one i just was
cracking up and i was like i just feel
like this is something that bill would
enjoy but anyway thanks for having me on
it's great to be here i love new jersey
because i really they seem to have the
same kind of meat heads
that they had in or around in boston you
know i don't relate to philly meatheads
or new york meatheads but when i go to
jersey i'm like these these people are
the same kind of stupid i am really
no they are they're like near the big
city but they're not in it they get that
suburban life but they're not like these
country bumpkins
and uh there's a lot of fights
a lot of guys you know a lot of people
like not saying i was a tough guy but i
just there was a lot of fights you know
in and around where i was growing up a
lot of guys with earrings that's kind of
out now how the one earring in the left
ear
i i don't know about that i i feel like
it's not gone away but i could be wrong
i have no idea i feel like a lot of
dudes have both ears pierced and that's
kind of the wave
wow i missed that i went i went the
other way i thought the earrings
disappeared
yeah i don't know maybe because all my
friends are old and they just got tired
of having to keep it not infected oh god
all your old ass friends no of course
they don't have anything like what are
you talking about my generation was the
lt generation where you had your
initials like a lightning bolt hanging
from your left ear oh well yeah that's
definitely over
all right now that you've trashed me my
age my friends and uh our jewelry styles
let's talk about your race since it is
black history month
yeah
so the other night i'm laying in bed or
last night whatever the hell it was two
nights ago i'm sitting there and i'm
trying to go to sleep
um and you were watching
i watched something dumb with you
which i've given into it's kind of fun
it's a great way to bond because you can
get a lot of conversation going on
because what you're watching is so
stupid
um slash you talking through the whole
entire thing with your commentary and me
having to rewind because you just cannot
help
but like just be the commentator i'm
like i this doesn't need a narrator like
we can just watch it
we can discuss after
i'm working on that
i like on hulu because we don't have
hulu like without the commercials i
talked during the commercials have you
noticed that yes that's true but i mean
it's better than my brother my brother
why i will watch things with my brother
it drives me crazy and he literally acts
like he's in it like he'll respond to
people like the characters and whatever
lines they have he's responding as if
he's in the show and i'm always looking
at him like what are you doing i don't
want to like you know bring up
stereotypes here but are you saying he
talks to the screen no no no no no no no
no no no no
[Laughter]
note to self do not go to movies with
nia's brother i set myself up with that
one
oh my god that's so funny but anyway
yeah so what were you talking about what
we were watching yeah so you that woman
from a few years ago that white woman
who somehow oh god got passed
all the black people and we don't it's
it's spokane washington you can you
think it's spokane i thought it was
spokane the ether
no no no no
what do you what do you say he's all
right she's all right she's alright
spokane
cocaine um eric clapton okay
[ __ ] eric clapton um whoa
yeah why well we can get into that
another time um what did eric do
don't say it like he's a good friend of
ours what did eric do
he's like a kind of a documented racist
he's being a weirdo documentary he has
the papers he's got the paper the
receipts as they say today the receipts
um
uh
also isn't he like some sort of crazy i
don't know i don't want to get into it
um
but suffice it to say i i'm not a fan we
can we can google it after this but we
were watching the documentary which i
don't know why
when this documentary came out we're
talking about rachel dolezal
okay
when the documentary came out i was
really wait is your last name dole and
you're saying is all we're talking about
is all no do lejo or something when the
documentary first came out i was really
[ __ ] annoyed because i was like why
are they giving the psychopath
any kind of a platform and i didn't give
a [ __ ] i was like i really give people
backstory who the hell she is
oh rachel dolezal is the white woman
that pretended to be black
and she was like the head of
the naacp chapter and spokane washington
and she got it she ascended that high
before anybody noticed it's the funniest
[ __ ] ever after reporting a hate crime
that she was getting hate mail
which you know she actually might have
been getting
but
they think she put a banana on her
windshield and then took a [ __ ]
picture of it mother and some other
things she wasn't the only one um i
guess getting hate mail
but anyway
she got exposed by this reporter asking
her if she was actually black and she
tripped up and she was like well i don't
understand the question and then she
like ran away he was like are these your
white parents right exactly and so
it got into this whole you know
situation about her being exposed and so
this documentary which like i said i had
resisted because i really didn't care
and i thought she was crazy i was like
you know what and why i started watching
why i'm watching it during black history
month i i can't i can't i can't defend
that well maybe you need to roll over in
bed and see what you married well maybe
that's it i was like i'm looking at you
and i'm like why like why are white
people so anyway i um
finally decided to watch it
and i haven't finished it
listen this is what i'll say
if there's any white people
confused
about why this was an issue for us
i think you need to watch the
documentary black people we i think we
already get it i mean i guess it was
something i don't know that we were
confused i think the only person
confused is the subject of this
documentary and she just refuses she's
now saying that she's transracial that
she transitioned
and then the other thing i couldn't
believe you know being a bald son of a
[ __ ] now i don't know if you've noticed
that
you just go sure we got to get two
microphones so people can hear you
trashing me they can hear it okay well
the fact that
her braids were so tight that her she
was she was getting the receding uh
she lost her edges she lost her edges
i mean that's how dedicated she was to
this this game i'm gonna say you know
does she get any points for that any
points for what
well you know like justin timberlake you
know he kind of before the super bowl
okay he brought sexy back
and i believe black people were air
quote [ __ ] with him uh-huh uh-huh
yeah well i would think you know if you
were so committed to the cause
that you were [ __ ] pulling your
hairline back towards your spine
maybe that's what threw off the people
and spoke spokane they were like going
well look no sensible that's exactly
what it was a person would do that there
was black women who are always the first
to tell you when something is wrong so
you know i know people like to be like
oh listen to black women but but yes
because we we know but because there was
a there were women on there black women
who were like i didn't want to be mean
but to me she looked like a white woman
in a black woman's wig and that's
exactly what she looked like not to
mention the fact that she was making up
her face in such a way that she looked a
few shades darker sometimes she wouldn't
she was putting on bronzer like she was
gonna have like a flex off with
schwarzenegger in the late 70s yeah but
it was it was i will say that it was a
little bit illuminating to see
why
she
did what she did she basically has
childhood trauma that i feel like she
still hasn't resolved and you know you
felt for her
sons who never asked for any of this
and you feel really oh my god her sons
are so cool and they're just like
monotone i think it's a form of
depression if she could just stop doing
putting them out there and just [ __ ]
leave them okay let's let's let's let's
wrap this up nia okay well this part
last part of the of the the show is
called help bill pass
pass what
i what if i want to be the head of the
naacp in boise
reverse path transpassing
i don't think there's any hope just come
on no like
let's just say you know i went out and i
got some bronzer i don't know right
remember that and i went to
one of our first weekends away together
years ago
i got some like i don't know it was
supposed to be like like a sunscreen but
it was also sort of to help like bronze
you and i was like let me just see and
like i sprayed like the whole can on you
and nothing happened like you're tan
resistant even with like artificial
that's how real i keep it nia yeah like
it's just your body is like nope there's
zero zero melanin to enhance
pat williams says i am from the isle of
caucus
caucasian
um
so you were saying if you were to get a
toupee yeah a to an ethnic toupee
right
something that john amos could wear and
i was to put that on my head but the
bronzer you know the photoshops are
coming
please don't
please don't photoshop bill in blackface
william transpass is the name
[Laughter]
um i just kept waking up and she was
just saying like astoundingly s
she said something that was just so
[ __ ] stupid i just
i kind of respected it as a comedian
because i knew how much it was going to
annoy the crowd
they asked her how she identified she
said unapologetically black she had to
fill out she she at the time of this
documentary she had just had another
baby and
she was saying that whatever
the mother identifies as i mean i don't
know if this is across the united states
or just in washington or whatever but
whatever race the mother is that's what
they consider the child so she was like
well i will always be unapologetically
black she's saying this to her two
fully black sons they're not fully black
because they're her kids right no no one
of them
is biracial but the other one is
actually her adopted brother but then
she became his mom she took him on as a
mother those poor kids the the amount of
confusion that they have to unwind i
know it's terrible it's terrible so
she's terrible so she had you know the
audacity to put on this form she marked
african-american and white and it's like
just but she she is a very
troubled soul
and the thing is it's like she could
have done she could have maybe not been
the president of the the naacp chapter
that's still funny to me that that's
like the music man
where he had no instruments and he came
to town oh we got trouble she came in
totally the music man she's the music
but it's like she could have been such a
powerful ally
and been like i went to howard i studied
black history i really you know have an
appreciation and love for black people
she still would have been annoying i
would maybe but it couldn't but she
would yeah what did you do if i met you
and i said i went to howard i studied
black culture you'd be like shut the
[ __ ] up i mean yeah it would not have
gone much further than that because it
just so then why are you suggesting that
that's what she could do because i'm
just saying if she was really committed
to you know the advancements of black
people and equal rights and stuff she
could have done that as a white person
she didn't have to pretend to be black
that's the thing about it like you could
have done all the wonderful things that
you were doing and all the black people
who care about her that were on there
were like her heart was in the right
place she was doing so much for the
community she really did but she lied
about who she was so she ends up
undermining everything that she did
and that's what's really unfortunate
about it is that she she undermined the
[ __ ] so this kind of finds feels like a
a hollywood movie before the redemption
when she turns it all away or like is
this like scrooge with braids
scrooge
the best christmas movie ever
um all right well nia
thank you so much for coming on
and helping to explain that that
whatever the hell you were watching i
just kept waking up going like are you
still watching this woman i can't finish
it i will eventually i mean i don't feel
like i necessarily need to i think i got
it
but i was just curious and it's one of
those things where when stuff like this
happens i do like to
get as much information as i can i feel
like this is the part of the interview
where i if i was brian gumbel i'd take
out my notepad and i'd start writing
things down so uh what what do you think
is the future and
as you're asking me yeah and in spokane
what is he writing i if if i could ask
anything of anybody in entertainment
what is brian gumbel writing down he's
writing his follow-up questions to the
end to the package that we all just
watched when he sits down across from
the ripple he asks him a question they
start answering and then he writes it
down like he's grading them
maybe that's my own insecurity i'm like
why are you writing i think he's
yeah i don't know if we're meant to
believe that he's just watching the
package that we just watched but i feel
like when he's writing it down he's
thinking about his question so he's
making sure
to get it like this is maybe the third
or fourth question that he's writing
oh and so it's still a good show it's
it's a great show i love real sports
with brian gumbel and i love you and i
love you all right there we go and
that's the end of the interview
yeah what are you getting me for
valentine's day it's also almost our
anniversary
right
what anniversary of being together not
our wedding anniversary but of like
being together isn't it in february yeah
somewhere in here somewhere
somewhere in here i met you with that
but somewhere but i remember what you
were wearing
when you first met me yeah really yep
what was i wearing
you had that white shirt on that was not
when you first met me that was like our
first date maybe or a second no that was
when i met you at that italian bar that
i then saw that guy drunk singing and
that's who's now been canceled chris
don't say his [ __ ] name
everyone knows who that is though no
they don't they don't okay how many guys
have been canceled i'm [ __ ] editing
that
out i don't know if what happened
all these people weighing in you didn't
say anything happened you just said you
saw him there
that's what i'm saying right
you seem like a nice enough guy oh jesus
all right let's wrap this he didn't try
to grab on me
[Music]
um oh
that was mean all right all right that's
the podcast everybody now we have the
bet mgm
segment where me and paul versi discuss
our
picks for the super bowl near you off
the top of your head
who do you like better the bengals are
the rams i feel like i live in la i
gotta i gotta go with the rams i feel
like you live in l.a too
i gotta near with the rams because i'm
an la person now all right try to just
try to say something football about it
what do you mean like the ram what do
the rams have to do on sunday i they
gotta get out there and they really
gotta have a strong defense an
incredible offense
and they gotta just drive that ball all
the way down and uh make those
touchdowns there you go
i think that was some great some great
insight really looking forward to the
halftime show
oh that's right dr dre snoop dogg and
mary j blige and what about that chick
from spokane you think she's going to be
there
she is going to be on instagram live
like trying to twerk to it and it's
going to be awful all right as long as
she's not spraying booze down on fans oh
my god all right this is uh okay so here
comes the bet mgm segment enjoy
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better podcast nfl
segment sponsored by bet mgm and guys it
is sad to say but we are in the last
game
of the season the one they call the big
one and we cannot wait to get up to get
to this all right it's the last game of
the season and we've got a super deposit
match for our listeners this week that's
right it's a big week if you still
haven't signed up for bed mgm use bonus
code burr b-u-r-r make your first
deposit up to 560
and get it matched in free bets
that means if you deposit 560 dollars
you'll have
1120 to bet with for the big game it's
pretty [ __ ] cool
no it's nuts it goes beyond pretty
effing cool it's insane it's it's
amazing actually uh oh you could have a
fun sunday
uh download bitmgm app and make sure
dude they're like what's this henry hill
peeling off the cash for you
uh those gamblers listening to this in
the shower oh son of a [ __ ]
um
when you sign up so all you got to do is
download the bet mgm app use bonus code
burr if you throw in
560
they are going to give you
double that 11 20 for the super bowl um
so make sure you guys sign up and do
that today now bill
people have been asking who you got who
you got i know people are asking you who
you got and we did have a pretty nice
regular season so do you want to take
the floor first i think we should do
like a minute or two minute explanations
each on who we're picking and why do you
want the floor or take the floor okay
you'll take the floor all right
you know sometimes you see a super bowl
paul
sometimes you just sit down you don't
care what the analyst is saying you see
it and it [ __ ] happens it happened it
hasn't happened to me in a little bit
last time i really remember it was when
everybody said 49ers and i said the
ravens
um i remember that yeah well this one
dude i just can't get a vibe on it
all right and i don't know what it is i
just i am not buying
was it sean mcveigh
yeah i don't know
i don't know i think he does what he
does i think the bengals have a good
enough defense to stop matthew stafford
i like joe burrow this is mostly my
heart though because i'm an lsu fan and
i just feel like this is an election
you know like the dumbest thing ever is
after they have the primaries and they
have the republican candidate and then
the democratic candidate and then then
they have the two of them everybody
knows who they're voting for
you're a democrat you don't give a [ __ ]
if they have a warmonger with dementia
you're gonna vote for that guy if you're
a republican you don't care if it's a
reality show tv star that says you know
not all neo-nazis are bad people there's
good people on both sides you don't give
a [ __ ]
right because your money's red and the
other people's money's blue well you
know what
my money is lsu
baby
and i think joe burrow
learned something
in that game when he got sacked nine
times against the titans he stopped
doing that fran tarkin and tucking the
ball and starting to [ __ ] you know
try to do the whole uh
run into the blurriness down here paul
you don't want to be down here in the
blurriness you want to be in focus
so i feel like he was throwing the ball
away
um
i just i just i don't know i just like
the uh
the bengals man i think they're a team
of destiny and they got that [ __ ]
field goal kicker who talks [ __ ] well i
guess we're going to the afc
championship game well i guess we're
going to the super bowl well you know
what paul i guess we're going to disney
world and i'm picking the cincinnati
bengals for their first and you take it
out with the spread
you're taking that with the score at
this point right
i thought the last i saw was four and a
half what is it andrew
four and a half and joe burrow
dude the bengals are [ __ ] so do
that's where the west coast offense
started with bill walsh before paul
brown shipped him away
i'm telling you all
all of those 49ers super bowl should
have been the bengals they've been
waiting for [ __ ] 50 years i gotta
feel it's their time
all right guys there you go uh bill burr
super bowl pick he's taking the
cincinnati bank based on emotion and joe
burrow
all right
i'm gonna say this
okay
everything that i've seen in football
and all the logic that i've seen in
football tells me
logically even though logic is out the
window with this
okay
because if logic existed joe burrow
wouldn't be sacked nine times against
the tennessee titans and still win
joe burrow wouldn't be losing 21 to
three in kansas city to mahomes and
still win
and we want to be making money earning a
living telling jokes there's no logic in
the world paul there's no logic in the
world um everything tells me that the
rams should win this game
defense wins championships the defensive
front of the rams is going against a
weaker offensive line i want joe burr to
win this game
i want to see this kid i love this kid's
swag he's got a chain over a turtleneck
who loves that more than me okay
he's walking in his hair is gelled he
talks a little [ __ ] when the when that
woman interview was asking him questions
he was doing that i'm cool joe wink [ __ ]
i love the kid
i do think though
the magic runs out
i do not only think the rams are going
to win and i want to be wrong if joe
burrow is listening to this i want
nothing more than you to win this game
stop hedging your bets
but
you you're sitting there you're you're
rooting for an unhappy ending he is not
protected well
he is not protected well and he was
protected well in that kansas city game
paul he was down 21-3 and he was she's
getting sacked in that game a little bit
too
a little bit paul i i think you're
making a mistake here i think you're you
watch the titans game and that's what
paul does he sees one thing and he's
like that's what it is listen i wanna
pick cincinnati but i think cooper cup
is gonna have the catches he gets i
think that that's gonna leave obj to
make some plays and i just like the
defensive line of the rams i think the
rams are going to win the game i think
the rams
are going to take cooper cup and that
leaves oh uh they're going to double him
so that leaves uh odell open i'm saying
that he's going to stafford loves going
to cup so much and that's going to leave
somebody that's going to leave a
vulnerable d back with uh with o'dell
i don't think you're giving cincinnati
enough credit paul you know something i
like money's starting to [ __ ] jump a
little bit in my wallet
i think it's coming your way paul i
think
what do you want to do i owe you 100 200
i owe you a hundred because of the
packers remember i said i'm just going
to hand you with one if that happens the
most italian bet
yeah ever don't think about it people
who missed the episode
what was the bet you said if i just said
if he doesn't if the green bay packers
is what he said before the nfc
championship game he goes bill if the
green bay packers do not make it to the
super bowl the next time i see you i'm
taking a brand new hundred dollar bill
and i'm sticking it in your front shirt
pocket and i go all right well what do i
have to do and he goes nothing
that was out of all the years i've known
you that's the most italian you've ever
been
that was like when chas palm and terry
in the bronx tale shook his head's over
it's over
before the mush no before it even before
they even did the final turn he goes
look so he starts shaking hands hugging
everybody um
yeah i'm taking the rams to win the game
i think the rams could and i think if
it's a blowout it would be the rams not
the other way around i could be wrong
and i kind of hope i am but i think the
rams are going to be i think you're
wrong paul i got 200 bucks says you're
wrong all right so me and bill so bill's
got the cincinnati bill's got cincinnati
i'm taking los angeles and we're going
to do a friend i've got 200 bucks with
you
that's what i'm going to die you and i
must make a bet so so me and bill are
going to also do a side that of 200. uh
200 i'm going to take the rams at home
i'm excited for the suit okay we're
going spread it we're just going
straight up we betting the money line
what are we doing here you and i
you think the rams are going to win see
that's the thing you think they're going
to win i think the bengals are going to
win
you don't hey you don't hey paul
this is how confident i am here's my
[ __ ] little italian swag from hanging
with you i don't need the points
i'll bet you straight up okay i'll bet
you straight up too hey i'm not telling
you i do you really want to bet with
[ __ ] freckles
i don't know why top 40 song is in my
[ __ ] head
um all right we'll go straight up 200
bones 200 bucks paul
and if i lose then i'm giving you 300.
i'm going to tell aaron rodgers i have
an option if you don't want to give me
the full 300 you can just give me 200
but you got to sing the lsu fight song
no no i want to give you 100 and i want
to tell aaron rodgers he owes me a
[ __ ] c note that's what i want to do
that's what i want that's how pissed i
am they used to be in that [ __ ] game
and social buffalo um all right this is
kind of cool for the show because you
got
and kansas city with those two [ __ ]
awful defenses ended up exactly where
they should be watching the super bowl
once the smoke cleared on that paul that
was the worst [ __ ] defense i think
i've ever seen in any game ever that was
a joke if you're josh allen what do you
say to the higher-ups that's like a
comedian
trying to get to montreal and just
crushing on all [ __ ] auditions like
standing ovations and then not getting
it going like should i look what did
josh allen need to do
no it wasn't his fault here's the thing
and they had one of the top rated
defense in the league and when it came
down to the big moment they they [ __ ]
choked
yeah they choked
that's all you can say kansas city all
that defense did was play how they
played all year turned terrible
are we i can't say all year we only have
15 minutes left here so let's get into
some of these prop bets which are
[ __ ] oh dude they got me going bro
can you explain to me and the listeners
when it's like when it says plus 550
does that mean i gotta bet 550 to make a
hundred
no to make one if it's 550 minus 160
that's the opposite it's the opposite so
if something is plus one thousand if you
bet a hundred you get a it you you you
get a thousand
so this is all best bet bet off uh it's
all based off betting a hundred dollars
right so this prop best says first
touchdown scorer of the game before if i
bit 100 bucks and cooper cup gets a
[ __ ] touchdown i get 550 bucks on
cooper cup
yes yup those sound like linemen odds
why is cooper cup why do they think he's
not going to get one that's first
touchdown
because it's got to be the first
touchdown of the game oh
so odell beckham jr is plus a thousand
to get the first touchdown of the game
you put a hundred on it and he gets boom
you [ __ ] you ten times so oh that's
that that was that year that guy bet
jack squirrick on the [ __ ] raiders
and he picked off a [ __ ] ball
yeah so the last guy nobody heard of
intercepted a ball for a touchdown
against the redskins
yeah that's the last guy on this list is
some guy ben
shkokrak
and if he gets the first touchdown of
the game it's plus 6600
but it's fun because you could put 20 on
it you could put 10 bucks on it and make
money
um
i'll tell you who i like for i i tell
you who i like in that bet
first touchdown of the game
you know who borrows plus four grand
that's that's the one i was just gonna
say it what if they get to the one yard
line and he [ __ ] jumps in there you
win four thousand dollars on a hundred
i'm doing that one i'm doing that one
um that's 4k dude what does bengal d
slash st mean
defense yeah if the defense gets like a
you know fumble pickup run special teams
special teams so you're telling me
the bengals
or the rams [ __ ] scoring a touchdown
but is is half the odds of joe burrow
doing it
he must never do it all day i'm sorry
he's fourth these four thousand
matthew stafford is
6600 yeah that's a good bet
if you put 20 bucks on that if you put
20 bucks on that you're making like a
whatever you're making money dude like i
think you're losing 20 bucks paul i
think that's what you're really doing
but like i know the pie in the sky no
dude how many times you guys are patriot
fans how many times is uh
tom brady on the one yard but that was
his move and tom was great at everything
except running
and that's why he was great at
everything because he couldn't run
all right let's go to let's go to super
he could hit every pass he could sneak
he could do everything but run
yeah
um
super bowl mvp odds
obviously joe birthday so who are you
picking paul first score who do you like
first scorer
i like for that bet for the money
i like joe burrow for plus four thousand
dollars
all right i'm gonna bring it to reality
i like joe mixon
i like a nice handoff and it's like a
[ __ ] eight-yard run too one of those
sweeps in there ever you see all these
ram jerseys and he just sort of [ __ ]
uh serpentines through the whole thing
that's what i'm seeing i mean do you
like a [ __ ] everybody sees that let's
get [ __ ] creative here
i like making money paul
what do you like paul [ __ ] meeting
some big fake titted [ __ ] in a strip
club and throwing [ __ ] 100 on her
that she's not going to cheat on you but
you're acting like a quarterback that's
starting can't get the first touchdown
of the game for four grand that's a good
bet
you know it's not like oh i just [ __ ]
played the videotape in my head and i
saw joe mixon running in okay all right
all right actually
come and be all hostile-like
no that's not bad oh god i'm gonna
sneeze like that guy who broke his ribs
um
joe mixon plus
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude you said he looked like he got shot
out of or he got sucked out of a
spaceship joe mixon that's a good bet
that's plus 750. yeah i want to win
money paul i mean anybody can go like
hey joe bag of donuts plus [ __ ] 10
000. i'm gonna bet 20 bucks on that i
mean yeah i'll [ __ ] throw money on it
but like i'm trying to win paul
all right all right i like my death by a
thousand twenty dollar bets
oh my god i hope he bootlegs and scores
oh your phone's going to be
by the way where are you watching the
big one
what are you doing
paul at this point it could be my living
room or i'm going to go to the game i
got a couple of buddies in town they're
trying to make some moves i don't give a
[ __ ] either way and then another buddy
mines go you know i'll stubhub if you
want to i'm like now
dude stubhub now it's like the worst
seat in the house is like 6k yeah [ __ ]
that um nick's grandpa you know how many
[ __ ] air jordans and track suits
that'd be for you
all right let's go to super bowl mvp joe
likes mixing the score the first time
well if you spend six grand on on air
jordans and track suits you'd have feds
outside your car outside your house just
watching you yeah it's stupid too
spending that money
um
this guy's got to be doing something
look at him
who do you like for the super bowl mvp
obviously both quarterbacks are the
worst odds because it usually goes to
them
so what are you going to bet paula
lineman i'm i'm trying to win money here
dude sony michelle is plus 8 000 but
running backs usually have to have like
250 yards and three touchdowns that's
not going to happen paul this is the
thing
this is the thing you either bet these
in reality or you make like just like a
bunch of [ __ ] small bets and
everybody oh plus 10 000. if i bet one
dollar i could finally get that above
ground pool i've been having my eye on
or you can get into reality all right my
reality for this one the reality pick
would be
i'm not gonna go stafford because that's
too too little but cooper cup is the
second one on the list and if that guy
gets 11 catches for 160 yards and a
touchdown or two it could be him and
he's plus 600 so i'll say cooper cup for
the super bowl mvp yeah i don't like
that bad i feel like they only give that
[ __ ] they'll give it to a wide
receiver if it's like [ __ ] lin swan
or or jerry rice i like joe burrow i'm
going right out over the play here paul
i'm trying to win money all right i
think the bengals are going to win and
they're going to give it to cool joe and
joe mixon's going to score the first
touchdown which is going to put the rams
on their heels you see this ball you see
what i'm doing here i'm i'm i'm painting
a picture all right i like it okay i see
what you're doing paul
you're on the ground with the 22
shooting at a [ __ ] police helicopter
[Laughter]
i mean hey you might take it down
you might take it down i don't know i'm
hoping to hit the rotor
there's a reason it's illegal paul
because you know something could happen
um all right bill this is one of your
favorites here the gatorade bath color
but before i before we do this i'm going
to be a friend to you
i'm going to be a friend to you because
somebody told me
somebody said
somebody said to me all right you're
going yellow but somebody said to me
they go just so you know
the bengals always have orange
and when he said that to me i was like i
wish you didn't tell me that but i'm not
gonna do this bet pick with bill and not
tell him that but you know what i'm
gonna do oh do you understand
that i'm an incredible friend this is
the easiest fixed [ __ ] bet ever
wow all it takes is one [ __ ] guy on
the staff
who's tired are these guys throwing
their [ __ ] water bottles at him and
he's got to pick him up and all the tape
and all he's got to do is put some
[ __ ] boo berry [ __ ] blue gatorade
in there
oh dude and he's gonna [ __ ] retire
purple that's a movie
that is that is imagine that that is an
arty lang [ __ ] star already starring
artie lang
what are you going then what happens is
they lose the super bowl and then all
the players blame him because he [ __ ]
with their mojo by having the wrong
colored gatorade and that's when the
cards start to fall
and now we got a road movie arnie's in a
car i'm watching that movie i'm watching
that movie too
um
dude purple is plus a thousand
yellow is plus 450 and blue is plus 300
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with um
you know what i'm gonna go
over the plate with this one i'm gonna
say blue i'm gonna say blue over sean
mcvay's head i like yellow all right
bill's got yellow i got blue i like joe
mixon i like joe burrow i'm going all
joe's
joe knows on this one paul joe knows
super bowls
all right uh first scoring play
rams rushing touchdown bengals rushing
touchdown rams receiving bango's
receiving um rams defense special teams
bengals defense special teams field
goals or safeties
obviously safeties are paying the big
money you stay away from that
um
oh you said you said you like cincinnati
rushing touchdown right yeah
all right
i i like surprisingly knocking those
front four backwards
i actually like cincinnati rushing
touchdown too because i think it's going
to be i think i think the rams will play
from behind and come back and win so all
right
um no paul you know you're saying one
thing but you're betting something else
a little crazy paul
but i like what you're doing you're
either gonna you're you're gonna be 100
on and you're going to come next week
wearing the [ __ ] schwammy hat
jersey number of first touchdowns scored
and cointoss what does that mean jersey
number
we just
i mean didn't we already do this by
picking the player let's let's do coin
toss i got i always go tails
all right i'm going heads
okay
all right as it is
all right totally take the [ __ ] ball
totally oh yes dude me and you were
gonna be this is one thing me and bill
are always in agreement on
anybody that wants to know with our
texts and our phone calls during a game
why don't you kick why don't you get the
points we are on the same page with that
take the [ __ ] points take the [ __ ]
ball
dude that [ __ ] that stupid-ass
[ __ ] bill the algorithm says if you
go for it on fourth down university of
cincinnati you won the toss what do you
want to do you want to keep the ball or
do you want to give it to alabama who
has the heisman trophy winner at [ __ ]
quarterback oh we'll give it to them and
see what happens
i said algorithm like a dick i meant
analytics
total yards made by field goals that's a
dumb bet i don't like that bit i'm
skipping that total yards by field goals
kind of i like that bet by the bengals
i'm going to say they're going to have
uh
under under 155. i'm going to say
they're gonna have
oh it's either under 190
or under three i think that he kicks
three field goals
they're all going to be in the 40s i'm
going to say under 55.
155.
under 155. all right i'm not touching
that one no no no you know what i'm
going to say on under a buck 90.
under a buck 90 because i think you know
one of the ones you know the rams
defense is going to stop him it's going
to be like a 51-yarder and he's just
going to come out he's just going to hit
paul like he was going out to go pick up
the morning newspaper
well looks like i'm going to hit a 51
yarder and he's going to walk out that's
exactly what the [ __ ] he's gonna do i
love when he kicked the warm-up kick and
he goes well i guess we're going to the
afc championship
yeah that's it
all right total yards made of field
goals okay we didn't want to do anything
now we're on the last one and i did this
prop bet on another bed mgm show
i said i think jamar chase of cincinnati
is going to have a 50-yard plus
reception i think he's going to catch a
25-30 yard pass and run for a bigger one
and that one is not on this list for
some reason but uh it's out there so oh
no it
uh over
oh longest hold on longest reception
is uh under
27.5 yards no no i like over that so i'm
gonna go with i think nfl defense is
stink now and cooper cup uh over 29 and
a half he'll have a 30 yard one he'll
catch one for like 17 and run another
13. i see that happening
bill what's your final score of the
super bowl if you had to pick final
score
um
gun to your [ __ ] head
i like 23 17.
okay pringles i like 29 18 rams
there you guys go look at this
half hour show
one minute away there you go
guys this has been the bet mgm segment
make sure you guys go to the app you
download the bet mgm app use bonus code
bur b-u-r-r you put in 560 dollars you
get 11 [ __ ] 20 to bet on the super
bowl have a good time it's unheard of
they're giving you half a g they're
giving you half a g go have fun enjoy
the game be safe drink responsibly check
bills monday morning podcast check my
versi effect go to my uh website i'm
going to be in syracuse coming up this
month pittsburgh all the dates are on my
website go to a show
uh andrew who do you got in the super
bowl you're the producer final word from
andrew themless the greek freak from his
compound in beverly hills who you got i
got the bengals by td
by what buy a td i think it's i think
it's gonna be like
you guys are ganging up on me
all right there you have it the greek
freak man a few words
taking joey b
up uh a touchdown all right guys enjoy
the game all right there you have it
those are our picks
uh love it or leave it bet your own way
or come our way whatever you got to do
everybody have fun bet responsibly do
not end up on real sports with brian
gumbel because you bet your whole house
just bet what you can afford to lose
have a good time have some dip
and uh enjoy the music right now picked
out by uh the great andrew themless and
then afterwards we'll have a bonus
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday february 10th
2014. how's it going how are you yes i
know i realize the podcast
is actually air quote on time this week
okay don't even start that [ __ ] it's
never late all right
i always tape on monday mornings that's
why i call it the monday morning podcast
you [ __ ] myopic [ __ ]
all right the only reason why you're
getting it this early on monday is
because i'm taping it on sunday the only
reason why i'm taping it on sunday which
i shouldn't even be doing because it's a
day of rest
all right it's a day to sit back after a
week of farming phil give your [ __ ]
oxen some oats
whatever you feed him hey
is that what you're feeding them i don't
want the [ __ ] you feed them
all right
all i know is they don't they're [ __ ]
jacked and then you never see them
[ __ ] drinking a protein shake do you
people are doing protein shakes you know
something years later when you get the
powder cancer i don't want to hear about
it okay you're drinking a goddamn
powdered shake
what are you on the [ __ ] jetsons
sit down and have a pork chop like the
rest of us
these [ __ ] idiots they know these
goddamn workout people first you go out
there and you dress like the green
lantern then you take out your little
[ __ ] powder thing your little thing
and you shake the thing up
and then you suck it down just have a
[ __ ] salad
you know dude you know pissed off those
people
who were selling the [ __ ] of nature were
me
they were actually upset
so they won't be on my podcast anymore
[Laughter]
they were mad
they were mad is this selling
that box full of lies
yeah you get hungry in the afternoon
yeah gee what do i do
you can have a [ __ ] banana get him an
apple you're going to be fine watch the
pounds melt off
i don't need you to come over with your
tray of snacks cigars cigarettes
cigars cigarettes
the [ __ ] out of here
okay and shame on you for going and
ordering that [ __ ] you lazy [ __ ] tub
of [ __ ]
i'm sorry now i know you're not supposed
to fat shame but you know it's time we
start [ __ ]
at some point you got to tell them to
like look i i know you can't see your
bootstraps but you still should try to
reach down and find them and pull them
up over your [ __ ] meaty fat flabby
shoulders
all right
you ate your way into this situation you
can eat eat your way out
just do everything that you were doing
the opposite way
it's like playing a record backwards
except now you're playing it the right
way you've been listening to it
backwards
right yeah about your parts it's some
days chocolate sundae ships
right
you gotta have it going the other way oh
it says some broccoli and brussels
sprouts isn't that a nice song
oh [ __ ]
i hate taping on sundays i'm not funny
on [ __ ] sundays there i admit it
just like god i need a rest
i don't have time for this [ __ ] i don't
have time to be silly on a [ __ ]
sunday
okay i i worked all goddamn week
do you have any microphones i had to
[ __ ] take out of a mic stand this
week do you understand how sore
my wrist is
for [ __ ]
hey how you guys doing all right all
right keep it going for whatever the
[ __ ] was just on in front of me all
right how's it going oh look at this guy
huh
this guy he's got snaps on his shirt oh
the button's too hard for you i'm the
smartest guy ever [ __ ] his job look at
me i'm amazing i got to do that every
[ __ ] night
on sunday i give it a rest
i don't say funny things on sundays
so you're probably asking yourself well
bill then why don't you just do it on
[ __ ] monday
i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why because um
my wife is actually sick
she's got a 24-hour uh virus which i did
not think was contagious
i thought she thought she had food
poisoning
is what it was what uh what i thought
was so i was laying next to her in bed
we're using the same [ __ ] bathroom so
basically i'm probably gonna get sick in
the next 24 hours so
what i'm trying to do is get this
podcast out before [ __ ] starts coming
out of me on both ends if you know what
i mean
all right i got the wife upstairs i'm
downstairs i feel like
i feel like my wife got bit by a zombie
you know and i have her upstairs chained
to the davenport there and i'm just
waiting to see if she's gonna turn
all we need is brad pitt in here telling
us what to do
we got ourselves a goddamn movie um yeah
so that's why uh that's why this thing's
actually out early and uh and once again
[ __ ] all you guys it'll be like uh i
hope she gets sick every week so it can
be on time and [ __ ]
i wish
the [ __ ] of nature on anybody who says
that
um
all right sorry that was me
it was all mean so anyways um this is
the podcast for this week uh has anybody
been watching the olympics olympics
olympics yeah yeah yeah nothing
i actually i really enjoy watching the
olympics
i like just watching the games i don't
like all the other horse [ __ ]
you know all the journalists complaining
that the water isn't running and all
that type of [ __ ] i mean am i the only
guy who watched all those cold war
movies coming up
when i was growing up you know what it's
like over there
you got the habs and you got to have
nuts there's like
20 people who have some [ __ ] over there
and everybody else is getting [ __ ]
it's it's
unbelievably corrupt
you know what's going on over there
you know
i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on i just want to watch the
[ __ ] games
you know i get it i get it they don't
they don't treat gay people
the way that they should i mean why
would they they they don't even have
running water over there
surprised they're not clubbing women
over the head and dragging them down the
street by their [ __ ] hair
um
have you read some of the [ __ ] that
they've said about gay people i mean
it's like fights is this from the
the 1800s
some guy in the russian government he's
this is what he said
um
he told gabe he also told gay visitors
to not touch the kids
like he's confusing pedophiles
with with gay people
i'm [ __ ] real no wonder the water's
not running over there now listen i
don't want to take a bunch of pot shots
at russia
i don't want to do this because
for some [ __ ] reason i actually like
him
i miss him
they were fun it's like when the red sox
are good and the yankees suck it's no
fun and for like the last i don't know
20 something years
they've been there they're in a rut
right now they're like the michigan
wolverine football program
like what the [ __ ] happened
when are you gonna get good again and
it's starting to get to the point like
[ __ ] are they gonna turn this around
so i don't know i don't even know what
to tell you i i you know
i don't understand
how you can have the technology to blow
up the world
and then still not understand humanity
at that point right
don't they get will and grace like
translated over there can't they see
that there's nothing to worry about
[Laughter]
have you guys watched any of the any of
the games i actually watched uh i
watched some of the the cross country
and i don't know if i'm
in some of the speed skating
like i watch this the snowboarding
i think is [ __ ] amazing but after a
while it just looks like they're all
doing the same trick
okay and i don't need a bunch of [ __ ]
from people in their teens and 20s with
half your head shaved and the rest of it
looking like a comb over i get it
i'm old
i can't tell the difference between a
backside fakie and a [ __ ]
gumby twizzler
360. whatever the [ __ ] you i don't i
don't know
i'm amazed
i don't know how they do it but i can
only watch
like four runs
that you know
uh i did just all looks the same i don't
know i know what they're doing you
[ __ ] you go down the hill
you jump on the on on the railing or the
banister whatever it is you do a little
grindy
thing
and then you land and then you come in
and then you [ __ ] do a little oh
whoop-dee-doopy-doo you grab it you grab
grabbing the board with the hands
that's a big move this is me trying to
explain it and i also learned that when
you go to land
you're actually looking up the hill you
have your head looking up there i'm
seeing my i would have looked downhill
you're supposed to look up the hill
all right
i've learned that
and um
i don't know then you do a lot of
high-fiving and hugging of other um
other people that you're trying to beat
for some reason there's a lot of
camaraderie in that sport other than
that i don't know [ __ ] about it
but the speed skating i like
and uh cross-country screen go figure
i like that [ __ ] because it makes me
want to go work out
like i was watching the women doing it
and i'm like they are burning so many
calories they don't even have titties
anymore
can you imagine i could get rid of the
giant titty that's right above my pubes
if i started cross-country country
skiing
that's what i'm getting out of it dude
these women were flying
okay up the goddamn hill and then
downhill they actually they said this
year they might actually hit speeds of
50 miles an hour and they are so
[ __ ] exhausted
by the end of it you cross the finish
line they they all of them collapse
and just fall in the snow
like they were going to make a snow
angel and then they just passed out from
too much booze or something
and then they're laying on the [ __ ]
ground
[Music]
doing that [ __ ] i'm just like i don't
know there's something about
you know what it is i'm not fast
so i like endurance [ __ ]
you know gymnastics and that type of
[ __ ] trying to hang from some doing iron
cross
like i look at that stuff and i actually
think like you know if i
tried to do that long enough i could do
it i couldn't do it at an olympic level
but i could do it
all right i can watch a guy run at 440
all day long dunk a basketball i
hit a [ __ ] home run
in a major league stadium i'm never
going to be able to do that [ __ ]
did i just say i could do an iron cross
maybe i'm already getting sick right now
maybe i'm uh
[ __ ] you i could do it
all i need some rings
and an old tree to hang them from
oh my god can you imagine
what what is even what is the muscle you
tear trying to [ __ ] do that
that's your lats
i wonder how long that takes to build up
the strength all right so all you would
do you'd [ __ ] hang them from the tree
you know once your wife is like don't do
don't hurt yourself
once you get through that
you know you people with kids i'm just
putting it up for the kids don't worry
i'll put some mats down and we'll put
some leaves here they'll be fine
i figured what you got to do you hang
have things hanging down and you got to
get into the dip position first
and then what you do is you gradually
start bringing it out
and then when you start feeling the fire
under your armpits you bring it back
real quick and just every day you go out
there every other day you try to go a
little bit farther is that how you do it
anybody can anybody who listens to this
podcast doing iron cross
do i have to be wearing like those pants
like defeat pajama grape smuggling
[ __ ] uh lower pants
lower pants
lower leotard
section of the pants there the [ __ ] why
do i try to do this on sunday that's why
i don't go to church
it's just sunday so you know i don't
[ __ ] i'm
i'm always coming back from the road i'm
always traveling you know i fly back and
then i'm just i just lay here catatonic
this isn't what i'm supposed to be doing
here trying to be [ __ ] funny
anyways i had a great show this weekend
i was actually out in uh
minneapolis minnesota
at this casino i believe was called
treasure island i was there so [ __ ]
quick
i flew in i did the show and i came
right back out it was like minus two
degrees the entire
[ __ ] time i was there
and that is a level of cold
you know like
i love the winner
i don't give a [ __ ]
until it gets down once it gets into the
teens that's when i give a [ __ ] that's
when i'm like all right enough already
but i don't even mind if it's in the
teens and christmas is coming it's when
it's in the teens and it's just february
or january that's when it's [ __ ]
miserable and it was so [ __ ] cold out
there even people from minnesota were
saying that it was like cold
but um
anyways i went out there and uh
had a great time thank you to everybody
who showed up
um
still on the wagon you know what's funny
after the show
um
i was hanging it was me and the other
act that was out there jade
cataprida i hope i said that right um
i've never known how to say the last
name i can't [ __ ] read
who [ __ ] killed it
in front of me by the way had a great
set so afterwards we're hanging and
we're hanging with the promoter and i'm
sitting at the bar and i'm not drinking
and i'm [ __ ] drinking oh duels
and like how many oh duels are you
literally gonna have so i i get one oh
duels and i'm just sitting there like
all right i'll sip on this [ __ ] thing
and smoke goddamn cigar or whatever
and um
so people after the show are going hey
can i get you a drink i get your drink
i'm like
i'm like no i really appreciate it thank
you for coming out but i'm not drinking
sorry
you know
you know whatever get jade one if she
wants one or blah blah so then people
started buying me
rounds they were buying me oh duels
so then i'm like well i gotta drink it
somebody gave it to me
so like an [ __ ] all the weight that
i've been losing because i haven't
boozed in like two weeks like now i'm
just sitting here pounding out duels
pounding
pounding oh duels
the dumbest [ __ ] like
the emptiest of all empty calories just
sitting there slamming things i gotta
tell you something for a non-alcohol
beer it ain't that [ __ ] bad and if
you have to be at a bar
you know it's i don't know
i think i found it i think i found see i
never yawn on monday mornings i think i
found um
i think i could go on a nice little run
here
if i can just still have my cigars i
have to have
some sort of vice
um would that be bad
if i go back upstairs right
and my poor wife why i you know thought
she's up there right now in gatorade
saltine cracker
um hell right now
um and she's cool too
she's cool about it she's cool with me
being down here you know a lot of women
would be like why can't you comfort me
you can at least sit in the chair near
me
i can't believe this laughing you know
and then you get sick and they're
[ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] right um
anyways
i didn't tell you guys this i i actually
bought off of ebay i bought a [ __ ] i
bought a drum kit
and you know the one thing that sucks
about drums is you cannot play them in
uh
unless you get it sound proofed in your
[ __ ] house
so i actually i got some drum cases
and i'm gonna bring these [ __ ] things
over i can't wait to play these goddamn
things i got an old ludwig kit
uh i know what you guys are saying send
me a picture i'm not sending you a
picture
just know that there it's an old ludwig
kit
on due time i will and due time let me
get my drummond up to a certain [ __ ]
level
because i know i've promised you guys
that i was gonna start doing drum covers
i gotta i i'll [ __ ] do one i just
gotta get somebody to videotape these
[ __ ] things
and uh and edit it and all that [ __ ] i
just don't know how to do that and
furthermore i don't want to learn how to
do it
i don't need another
goddamn hobby
i just i don't know you know what it is
i i have like computer phobia that's
basically earlier when i was trashing
everybody with the new phones and all
that part of that was true like i really
think you should pay down your debt
before you get another flat screen tv
before you get another [ __ ] phone if
i could just
get anything just get something through
to the listeners on this goddamn podcast
other than to go after what you want in
life as soon as you can
it would be
you know to just pay down your credit
cards don't start
a [ __ ] life or death
death
life of debt
before you even get married and start
having kids and then come out of it you
know
40 50 [ __ ] years later when you're in
your 60s or 70s
um i'm telling you
just live within your means
and you will have the gift of free time
you'll actually get a good night's
[ __ ] sleep
um
but anyways
yeah so but that um
generally speaking like i have i have
major uh
i know i learned a lot about myself in
the last week like my wife
finally convinced me that i have add and
i know a lot of you guys who listen to
[ __ ] are probably just laughing like
yeah how the [ __ ] didn't you know that
you know why because i'm the one trapped
in this [ __ ] skull okay
i'm sure you guys have problems too
don't [ __ ] come at me like that
trying to open up here
um i have the yellow windscreen
on the mic this week okay
trying to come from my heart here
i got a little sunshine on the mic here
um and i didn't think
i didn't think she was right she was
like no she goes i went on a website and
i
looked up add and you have every [ __ ]
symptom and i always just thought 80d
was just a crutch
like people i'm sorry i have add i'm
sorry i have add oh i got i have add i
saw people looks you know oh i drove
into the back of your car sorry i have
add like it just seemed like this
[ __ ] excuse it seems something like
for
just something that weak people said
so um i was just like no i'm i'm i'm
stupid
um
and i need to read more that's basically
how i looked at it
which still might be the case but um
i finally understood what she was saying
because she she read some of the
symptoms
and then i was sitting on the couch
and i was talking to her about the
patrice o'neill benefit coming up
and i was saying how happy i was that
you know
we're doing it two years in a row
we're helping out all the people that he
loved we're helping out people that you
know
you know diabetes stroke and that type
of thing we're giving some money to them
and i'm really talking about how psyched
i am
that everybody you know bought the
tickets and opie and anthony helped out
and all the comics like i mean i have
more than enough comedians on the show
this year they just said everybody loved
patrice want to be honest so i'm in the
middle of this heartfelt conversation
with my wife and and i'm sitting on one
end of the couches on the end and i sit
there and i kind of lean my head back
and i look up at the ceiling and i'm in
the middle is talking about how much i
love patrice and how much i miss him and
i looked up and i went oh a spider look
at that there's a spider up there
and i just started talking about the
spider
and then i hear her she starts laughing
and i look at her like what
and it was one of those things she
didn't have to say it she just had this
look in her eye like that [ __ ] we were
talking about earlier and she literally
buried her face in the pill and just
started laughing at me
and i was like
and i actually you know typical guy
thing i had to try to defend myself i'm
like no i mean there's a spider how do
you not address the spider
and then i really thought about it later
like the level
of emotional [ __ ] that i was talking
about and then just one stupid [ __ ]
spider
oh look at the spider like i and another
thing that when i go to leave the
[ __ ] house
i don't know maybe i'm trying to help
out other people who might have this
[ __ ] problem
all right is like and she told me she
should go well you should go talk to
somebody about it's like i don't want to
talk [ __ ] talk to somebody about it
they're going to give me a goddamn drug
that they push through the fda that's
going to [ __ ] up my liver and do
something else to me but i can really
focus when the doctor tells me i have
this new kind of [ __ ] cancer
whatever happened to just toughen it out
you know
you [ __ ] rogaine [ __ ] just go bald
like me
anyways
how many times do i say this what the
[ __ ] was i talking about same goddamn
thing this is it i have major [ __ ]
problems so she wanted me to go talk to
somebody about it i'm like i'm not
[ __ ] doing that
but uh i've just really noticed like the
amount of times
like take something simple
i'll have like a grocery list or
something
if i ever made a grocery list in my life
let's just say for shits and giggles i
do i'll have that
on my or
my phone or something like that i have
my phone and i'm going to leave the
house and i go oh [ __ ] where are my keys
i need my keys
so then i walk over
and i go over and i pick up my keys
all right see you later honey and i walk
out of the house i sit in the car i turn
on the [ __ ] car and then i look
around where's my phone
where the [ __ ] i left in the [ __ ]
house
how did i do that i had the phone i knew
i needed the phone i needed the keys and
it's just like i walk up there and my
brain is thinking about 90 other [ __ ]
things
other and and somewhere in there is i
need the keys
and i walk over to get the [ __ ] keys
i guess with the same hand and i set
down the phone it's like almost like you
know when you when you black out drunk
it's like technically you passed out but
somebody is still awake in your body
walking around talking to people that
you're later gonna have to apologize for
it's kind of the sober version of that
for those of you who aren't afflicted
with this
whatever the hell i have
maybe that's why i suck at reading
i don't know what it is
because i i really want to sit here and
say that i'm not a dumb guy but [ __ ]
everything
and i always talk about how much i
sucked in high school
i've been when i'm at one time like
we had to do a book report and i got
this book
it was about this german shepherd in
world war ii that fought alongside this
guy it was a great [ __ ] book
um
and uh
i remember the first night i sat down to
read it and it took me
like
four hours
couldn't make four it was like three
hours to read 30 pages two and a half
hours to read 30 [ __ ] pages
and the next day i went into school
i still remember the kid i said this to
i said yeah man it took me [ __ ]
i was reading the book for two and a
half hours and they were like how many
pages are you gonna take wow how many
pages into you and i said 30.
and he just started laughing at me
and i said to him he goes i go what
he goes it took you two and a half hours
to read 30 pages
and i was like what i i i said i read to
understand
and he just started laughing at me
thought that was the funny he thought i
was trying to be funny
and what i was really was trying to
convey to him was i had to i kept
reading paragraphs and my brain would be
thinking about other [ __ ] i had to go
back and reread it
over and over and over and over again
so i had to go that slowly so i could
understand it it was basically my
naive way of i guess explaining
look all i'm saying is if i don't have
add i am surprisingly stupid
[Laughter]
[Music]
but whatever
it's helped me in life maybe that's why
i can't write a [ __ ] script
but i can write bits because this is
short
right you know what i like about this
add [ __ ] i can explain away all my
problems
this is phenomenal hey cleo
cleo
guess what
i have added
all right does that mean anything to you
she's looking at me right now she was
laying down she just picked up her head
she was awake by the way it's one of
those deals with it she's got one ear
down and one ear up
you know can you get any [ __ ] i
challenge you right now to tell me
something cuter in the animal kingdom
than a [ __ ] jacked animal that could
rip your [ __ ] face off that anytime
it decides to
waking up from a from a nap with one ear
down and one ear up come here cleo
come here buddy
come here
oh big stretch
big stretch come here let me fix your
ear
i'm not saying jump up on the bed
there you go that's her saying hello
sniffing the microphone what's up buddy
even your head has muscles
huh
this is what i do every day
because even i don't know how to express
love
this is what i do every day with cleo
i grab her by both ears
not hard
no she's walking away i grab her by both
ears
and i just make her look up at me
and when she looks up at me i just go i
[ __ ] love you
[Music]
that's how it is
i love that dog so much i want to
[ __ ] tackle it every time i see it
isn't that right cleo huh you're helping
me live longer cause i gotta take you
out every day
[ __ ] shit's like a horse
um
anyways
oh you know what we got to take a break
for some advertising that i haven't even
gotten yet so i'm gonna have to drop
these in so through the magic of radio
not right of editing i should say
hey don't wipe your ass on the rug
she rarely does that
i still like the [ __ ] thing anyways
just making sure there you go go over
lay down
um through the magic of editing
here's some uh here's some here's the
first group of advertising for this week
okay and now the advertising this week
dropped into the podcast to the magic of
editing
sherry's berries everybody
hey how did you meet your significant
other
create another unforgettable moment with
sherry's berries
you can talk about learning how to give
the right gift
finally getting it right talk about how
much they enjoyed the product oh that
isn't part of the copy
i i don't understand these [ __ ]
people
all right giant freshly dipped
strawberries from sherry's berry
starting at just 19.99 for an a 40
savings or double the berries for just
10 dollars more you just need my code
bur b u r r when you order i'm assuming
it's burr there's it's blank there
uh dipped in white milk and dark
chocolatey goodness topped with
chocolate chips decorative swizzle
or nuts
40 percent off from sherry's berries
enormous romantic fresh juicing
mouthwatering berries right in your
mouth
here's the only way to get this amazing
valentine's day gift
giant freshly dipped strawberries
starting at just 19.99 or double the
berries for just ten dollars more visit
barrys.com
that's b-e-r-r-i-e-s
dot com click on the microphone in the
top right hand corner and type in burr
b-u-r-r go to berries.com click on the
microphone and type in bur b-u-r-r hurry
offer ends on thursday
oh [ __ ] you know what i just realized
i'm supposed to read these before i read
them
so their copy isn't wrong
my apologies to everybody yet share
these berries
all right the classic
the one that everybody loves dollar
shave club
for a couple of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality razors right to your front door
not only does it save you a ton of cash
it saves you from trudging to the
drugstore for a pack of blades i always
get stuck behind the family of four
trying to buy ice cream and develop
their photos from the disposable camera
um
but now i don't have to do that anymore
because dollar shave club for just a
couple of bucks a month amazing quality
razor blades are delivered right to your
door that's right no more wasting time
and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks
every time you go to buy razors
everybody here meaning me is getting
their dollar shave club blades and you
should too and here's a genius idea try
replacing your old shaving cream with dr
cabbies easy shave butter
from dollarshaveclub.com trust me your
face will thank you later don't waste
time at the drugstore behind the lady
paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank account
balance high shave time and shave money
go to dollarshaveclub.com forward slash
burr
there you go
look at that i think that was damn near
a perfect read
all right another one for valentine's
day everybody pro flowers
pro flowers you already got our
chocolate covered strawberries from
sherry's berries you got your face clean
shaven from dollar shave club what is
there left to do
simple you got to get her some flowers
valentine's day stories about
uh
mistranslations etc valentine's day is
this week when she says she doesn't need
flowers she means you better get me
flowers okay get we got bought a pain in
the as it is to go down to the damn
flower store with every other loser guys
standing there trying to get the last
bit of you know
the flowers are half dead all right by
the way when the the more the flower is
open the closer it is to death i
actually learned that from the late
great patrice o'neill who believe it or
not used to sell flowers at some point
in his life
he told me that i never forgot it
anyways they got the fresh flowers here
pro flowers get one dozen long stem
assorted roses with a premium vase and
gourmet chocolates for 29.99 or double
the roses that's two dozen roses long
stems and the premium vase and
chocolates for just 9.99 more
and you won't find a deal this good
anywhere else this week so for 40 bucks
you get all that okay pro flowers is
quick and easy and delivers on
valentine's day deliveries on
valentine's day is guaranteed even if
you already have valentine's day plans
you need flowers you got to get them it
it's the you put the cherry on top and
it's this is so perfect for guys
it's so perfect all you got to do is
just order it you don't even have to get
away from your desk you can literally be
watching the game in between periods you
can order how do you do it here's the
only way to get the valentine's day deal
one dozen long stem assorted roses with
a premium vase and chocolates for 29.99
or double the roses for just 9.99 more
go to proflowers.com click on the blue
microphone at the top of the top right
hand corner and type in burr burr that's
proflowers.com click on the microphone
and type in burr burr order today this
deals is only around while supplies last
and valentine's day is this friday
okay
stamps.com everybody
oh jesus stamps.com everybody you've
probably heard the cost of stamps just
went up to 49 cents but not if you have
stamps.com with stamps.com you pay less
for postage
you'll pay less for postage than you
would at the post office for first class
mail priority and priority express mail
packages and more stamps.com is easy to
use and convenient buy and print
discounted stamps shipping labels and
more using your own computer and printer
not only will you save money with
stamps.com by not paying full price
postage you'll save valuable time too
stamps.com always keeps the rates up to
date so you'll ne so you'll get the
exact postage you need every time right
from your desk never go to the post
office again i use stamps.com to send
out all my posters and my dvds i've
never had a problem right now use my
last name bur burr for this special
offer no risk trial plus 110 bonus offer
that includes a digital scale and up to
55 bucks free postage you can't mess
with this one don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur b-u-r-r
that's stamps.com enter bur free scale
55 postage 110
offer
that's what it's worth
what am i trying to say you don't have
to go to the post office again don't be
an idiot stamps.com all right
legalzoom everyone
some things like starting a business or
protecting your family with the will
aren't like your other new year's
resolutions you can't afford to blow
this one off all right instead of less
snacking and more exercise put put this
at the top of your list legalzoom helps
you incorporate or form an llc with
their simple questionnaire starting at
just 99. over 1 million entrepreneurs
have already done it and 90 of our
customer customers recommend legalzoom
to friends and family you can also
create a will starting at just 69 bucks
or even a living trust quickly and
easily and get peace of mind and
protection no surprise fees no hassles
man and no headaches legalzoom step by
step process was created by a team of
legal experts in law and technology
legalzoom is not a law firm but can
connect you with the third party
attorney and provides you with the
self-help services
from wills to business sorry from wills
to business formations trademark powers
of attorneys and more go to
legalzoom.com for even more savings type
in burp b-u-r-r into the referral box at
checkout don't put off the things you
need to do go to legalzoom.com now and
use discount use the discount code burr
that's legalzoom.com discount code burr
all right and last but certainly not
least
e-voice everyone
all right you're a business
owner
but automated phone system and
secretaries are not in your budget
they're not in your budget just yet and
juggling incoming calls yourself it
doesn't make you look like a
professional
all right you want to make money here
you want to look like a pro here's what
here's something you can do that will
dramatically help you make more money in
2014 it's called e-voice everyone
whether you're a business of one or 100
e-voice will help you manage all of your
incoming calls with a toll-free number
dial by name directory and call routing
tools your business will sound like a
million bucks can't take a call no
problem evoice will transcribe the
voicemail and email it to you uh never
get caught off guard again and with
e-voice you can try it before you buy it
right now just for my listeners you can
get a 60-day free trial to e-voice go to
evoice.com and enter the promo code bill
bill at checkout take charge of your
business and make more money in 2014 go
to evoice.com and enter bill at the
checkout for your 60-day free trial
that's
dot com promo code bill and that is the
advertising and with the magic of
editing we are now returning to the
monday morning podcast
okay and we're back
how about those reads well those things
awesome or what i have no idea
i hope they went well
uh oh you know the one that i always
forget to bring up is amazon.com
everyone if you shop through amazon.com
like i do if you'd like to donate to
this podcast here's a wonderful thing
you can do just go to billboard.com
click on the podcast page you look over
on the right there's the amazon.com
banner you click on that takes you right
to amazon
and i know it's an extra step but um
if i drive traffic traffic to this site
they give me a kickback on whatever you
guys buy it doesn't cost you any
any more money
it just takes a little bit of your uh
little bit of life out of your index
finger with a couple extra clicks that's
all that's all it is if you'd like to do
it do it if you don't i understand
you're busy
you got [ __ ] to do
um
all right let's move on here
hey how [ __ ] weird and awful
is right after the super bowl
that first sunday
without football i don't know about you
guys but it's always so god damn jarring
um
because you're so watching the playoffs
and you're so getting into it you're so
trying to guess who's gonna win the
super bowl and [ __ ] get your bets
going and all of that [ __ ]
that you don't even contemplate that the
second that game's over football is now
done
done until september [ __ ] that [ __ ]
in august
all right it's done
until september
what in god's name are we gonna do now
i'd say turn on the [ __ ] hockey but
it's the olympics
so
i actually can actually watch women's
hockey because the men's hockey doesn't
start for a minute please
everybody do me a favor watch some of
that olympic hockey sit down and enjoy
it it's gonna be phenomenal and when you
do enjoy it don't say that dumb [ __ ]
like
like everybody says actually tweeted
about this
you know
every four years during the winter
olympics people who don't watch hockey
get to lie and say that if nhl if the
nhl
was like olympic hockey that they would
actually watch olympic hockey you
wouldn't
you would you're either a basketball
person or a hockey person there's very
few people who have the time to watch
both
all right
another thing that always happens during
the olympics is when people praise the
olympic game
um they start talking about the nhl like
it's still 1975.
i heard uh
mike wilbon who i love
and one of the few shows that actually
like pti on uh
espn he even hinted like that he goes
it's great i love the olympic hockey you
know if the nh he goes you know if the
nhl would get the fighting and all this
stick work
all this what does that mean all this
stick work
what the [ __ ] what does that mean that
guys are just clubbing each over the
[ __ ] head
you know why they say that because once
every four or five years goes by
somebody does that [ __ ]
actually club somebody in the face with
a goddamn st and then that's the thing
that gets on sportscenter and then all
these people who don't watch hockey at
all
or or or
watching and passing then start going
like see this is the kind of thing they
need to get this out of the game
and they always go in the fighting dude
there's i've been saying this for years
i said this in 2010 during the olympics
there's barely any fighting
left in nhl hockey compared to the way
it used to be
okay
back in the day you used to have like at
least two if not three guys
on every team who were on your team to
beat the [ __ ] out of the other two to
three guys that were on that team to try
to beat the [ __ ] out of your guys like
when i was growing up when i first
started watching the bruins they had
john winsick and stan jonathan and one
of our all-star players the heart of the
team was terry o'reilly
and he fought just as much as he scored
back then he was known as a complete
player he could do whatever he wanted to
do you want the puck in the net
i don't know how good he was at defense
but whatever
he gave it his all you want to drop the
gloves he could [ __ ] do everything
wayne cashman was another guy
i mean he was like a goal scorer that
guy and he he i just remember fred q
said oh cashman with the left oh he had
this left hook
um
and then i caught the tail end of those
guys
and then it was jay miller lyndon byers
along the way we'd pick up guys like
willie plett
and then the islanders the islanders had
all these guys great
hall of fame tough guys
chris nyland john cordick
everybody and they were on the same
[ __ ] team
okay
now that like i don't even know how many
like actual goons
straight up [ __ ]
fighters i'm not gonna say goons are are
still in the goddamn league
like right now the bruins have won
sean thornton and he can actually play
the game i know a lot of you guys going
to say what what about what he did
against the penguins that's going to
happen
okay
especially when you give somebody a
couple of love taps and they they
actually somehow get knocked out i don't
want to be a dick but i think i could
have taken those punches
[Music]
oh here come the emails from the penguin
fans
um and i know what uh what they're gonna
be saying is they're actually
gonna say well why is there fighting
why is there fighting in hockey
which is the dumbest [ __ ] question
ever with it's like you're gonna address
that and say well why is there fighting
period
why is there fighting in boxing
why is there fighting in the ufc why is
that okay
but if every once in a while it happens
in hockey it's the most just
you know deplorable [ __ ] thing that
ever happened and now you got to make
comments on society in the direction
that it's going in
dude the bruins played the [ __ ]
canadians a couple weeks ago and i'm
pretty sure there wasn't even a fight in
it those things
by halfway through the first period
once a year they'd have that game
halfway through the first period there
would be like nine guys
in the penalty box and like [ __ ] i
don't know what that's even possible
they
they would be standing room only
in the [ __ ] penalty box
and now they'll play each other and they
just play the [ __ ] game
without having any fights but the fights
are part of the goddamn game
and so i understand if you don't like
hockey
because of the fighting but for the love
of god please quit complaining about it
because they're ruining the game because
they're going to take fighting out of it
and you're not going to watch it you're
not gonna watch it you're gonna watch it
the way i watch curling i watch it once
every four years and i really enjoy it
and i think like wow i could actually
watch this sport like i'm really gonna
go out and get the curling package and
start watching it religiously every
[ __ ] year
i'm not gonna do it all right so for the
love of god please enjoy the olympic
hockey and watch it but keep your
[ __ ] uninformed comments about the
nhl to yourself because it's an
unbelievable game it's a great league
and one of the reasons why it is so
great
is because not as many people watch it
as the other three [ __ ] leagues
you know
i just love that people [ __ ] still
[ __ ] about hockey and like the [ __ ]
nba had a mobbed up ref
literally shoeless joe jackson kind of
[ __ ]
and they just gloss it over i mean it
was a story but it was like wow we had
one bad apple
one bad apple
the [ __ ] guy prevented the sacramento
kings from going to the finals
the lakers got another ring or an
opportunity i'm not taking away the fact
that they won in the finals
but this [ __ ] guy admitted
that he fixed the goddamn series
so that they had they have a
championship
just like when when the white sox threw
the world series you have the same thing
going on except it was done by someone
on an officiating crew
and i've you hear more [ __ ] about the
fighting in hockey than you heard about
that it's unfucking believable i
actually got a friend of mine
who will remain nameless
and he claims this i don't know why he
would lie
he was working for uh
oh this is tough
i gotta watch out i'm gonna get sued he
was he was working for a basketball team
that i'm not particularly fond of
that i may or may not have made fun of
on numerous times
and may have already made fun of them on
this podcast about championship claims
but i'm not going to say who they are
their way uniforms remind me of barney
the dinosaur all right that's for
anybody who doesn't watch sports you
can't figure it out
all right they worked
at the arena
and there was one game left
and this team was playing another team
that was up north where it rains a lot
but they didn't lose their basketball
team
and there was one game left in the
series
and the guy who just stepped down
told the people for the barney the
dinosaur team to [ __ ] order all the
craft service or something like that the
[ __ ] get the seat set up for the
media and all that
but he only set it for the barney the
dinosaur team not for the rained out
[ __ ] team
and the barney the dinosaur team like
before the game even happened
he was claiming
that
there's no [ __ ] because he he knew
somebody who was in the uh
the [ __ ] uh
the other team's front office and they
were not given instructions to get
prepared for the next playoff series so
it wasn't like we need to be prepared
just in case he only told one team to
[ __ ] do it and it ended up being the
team that won now i know that that
sounds [ __ ] crazy i'm not saying it's
true i'm not saying it's not true but
all i know is for [ __ ] years i was
saying the nba is fixed and then i'm
vindicated when they have a [ __ ]
mobbed up ref and it's like a [ __ ]
goddamn like it was maybe a 10-day story
it was really hard for a couple days and
then that was it it just went away
yeah we just had one one [ __ ] guy one
mobbed up ref
[ __ ] a team out of a championship
chance to win a championship that's all
but the fighting oh and and the stick
work
the the tom foolery it just has to stop
you don't even have to watch hockey at
this point to criticize it so many
people have criticized the [ __ ] thing
you can just say what they say
all right i'm done i'm done i got my
[ __ ] i got my panties and a bunch
here
um all right let's let's let's read some
uh
let's read some of the the the [ __ ] here
for the week some of the uh the uh what
do you call these things here see
there's another thing too that's my add
i can't remember things because i have
add
why'd you take your dick out in public
bill i'm sorry i got add
um all right yo billy d williams my
chick is a die hard niner fan and after
five years dating her i've gotten into
my i've gotten into football myself
others consider me a conspiracy theorist
oh jesus now we're going right into
conspiracy here right after 9 11
i called it that the patriots would win
to symbolize the phoenix style rebirth
of american patriotism sure enough the
patriots won
all right i'm going to go with you on
that one
dude i called it all right
he said this year i made another
prediction that i was really hoping
would be wrong i had a feeling that
seattle
the team icon which remember resembles
the america's bald eagle will beat
denver's horse team which represents
china's year of the horse
this to symbolize the west's domination
over the east
to further support my previously stated
theory they were there were a ton of
pro-soldier and patriotic commercials
i'm very curious to see what political
events are to come in 2014.
thoughts
yeah dude you're you're way too far down
the [ __ ] rabbit hole
i've never understood that thing like
like the symbols on tv thing
that's always to me seem like paranoid
thought
um and [ __ ] everybody right now who
thinks my nba [ __ ] is paranoia they had
a mobbed up ref go [ __ ] yourself
um it was fixed
i'm not saying straight across the board
but it was fixed on a certain [ __ ]
level this [ __ ] here like first of all
all right seattle's team which resembles
an american bald eagle
uh it doesn't
it doesn't we'll beat the horse i gotta
tell you i didn't know it was the year
of the horse and i think i pretty much
represent the average joe
and uh
a seagull doesn't a seagull does not
look
like what's on the side of of the
seahawks and a seagull [ __ ] seahawk
i'm an [ __ ] i didn't realize i was
saying that
a seahawk does not look like a [ __ ]
uh
a bald eagle it doesn't a real one
doesn't the one that they showed
looks nothing like the cartoon version
that they have on the side of their
[ __ ] head and even if it does
okay the average [ __ ]
the way you have to spell stuff out i
mean the average [ __ ] is ordering uh
the [ __ ] from nature there and having a
box of [ __ ] chocolate-covered peanuts
delivered to their desk
they're gonna stick those in their mouth
and then wonder why they don't have abs
do you think they're gonna be able to
figure out the american bald eagle and
the denver's horse i'm a patriots fan
all right
like i don't think it
i i just never made the connection
i i think you're you're looking
so you're saying the illuminati is also
running a football league
[Music]
now what if the falcons won
what would that what would that have
meant
the green bay packers what what you know
do all of them symbolize something like
every year somebody who won last year
who the [ __ ] won last year i don't even
remember
i'm usually good about that [ __ ] two
years ago the giants when i remember
that because they beat my [ __ ]
patriots
what does that mean that giants are for
the taliban
yeah dude i i think that you're um
like if the 49ers win it that means like
we're coming back to slave labor
you load 16 tons and what do you get
big jump
big jump big bad drone
um
yeah dude i i think that uh i think
you're you're
you're kind of going beautiful mind
there
you're reading the daily paper you're
trying to to see stuff
that isn't there um
yeah
to symbolize
what the west domination over the east i
got to be i got to be honest with you i
don't understand
you know as far as i'm concerned china
is west of where i'm at
so how are they in the east
i mean when i fly to china if i ever go
to china i'm going to go west
they're going to fly me up to alaska
make a left and then go right by [ __ ]
south korea hopefully you don't get shot
down as we go by russia
and then i'm in china
i'm not going to go east
how did they decide that is that because
that's where we were populated like if
everybody came from africa
like nas and all the rappers say
you know because they've done their
research in between blunts
um
[Laughter]
um if we actually all came from there
then why doesn't the day start right
there because i know i understand we're
living on this
here
that the world is round
who's to say where the day starts
why does it start in japan
all right sorry there you go it was a
nice little [ __ ] minute and a half to
make you feel better about yourself
intellectually moving on
all right championships in seattle
billy bowl face
i'm not sure if you heard about this but
seattle has a few championships in
women's basketball
um obviously no one gives a [ __ ] but
this is what's great
i imagine the women who play on the team
give a [ __ ]
and those 37 people who are related to
him in the crowd i'm sure they do oh
[ __ ] that's too close to a joe bartnik
joke um
i imagine they give a [ __ ]
let's see he says there's a great
picture going on around
a round of a headline
seattle's first championship from a
seattle newspaper below the headline is
a picture of a player from the seattle's
women's basketball team as she's looking
up at a bunch of banners for
championships that they've won
well don't they mean like the seahawks
first championship because even if they
are sexist when they realize that the
supersonics
won a championship
do you wait a minute do you not and do
do you like not count that one now
because the sonics moved to uh
to oklahoma city and became the thunder
i don't understand that like you know
it's cool this weekend i saw somebody in
the crowd at a minneapolis lakers
t-shirt i thought it was great and i was
telling them i go those five
championships i you know
as far as fans go you guys claim those
the franchise
you know has the trophies but the fans
those are your championships
right
has to be
it has to [ __ ] be
if if the lakers move to [ __ ] las
vegas and won again next
next year
what would what would los angeles fans
do if they started going yeah we got 17
[ __ ]
you'd be like well wait a minute no 16
of those who won in la and then
minneapolis fans we had now five of
those
eleven championships won in la five won
in minneapolis one of them was in the
[ __ ]
baa
oh jesus bill
let it go now go [ __ ] yourself i like i
like being a [ __ ]
um
so yeah i mean
women's championships don't count as
much because of women
it's their fault
it's their fault
because guys don't sit around watching
the wnba we keep supporting the nba what
women need to do is say [ __ ] the nba
and just start watching the wnba and
what they should be doing is they should
be selling out those arenas
cheering on
the women there that's who needs to do
it
right
then they should all get together
with all their alimony money and they
should buy out the men that started the
wnba and they should run it themselves
and then no longer do you need the nfl
to be wearing pink in october you could
[ __ ] be wearing it all year in your
league
jesus christ
i don't know if i just solved some
problems or uh offended everybody from
cancer survivors to uh
people with the vag over there um i
don't give a [ __ ] whatever take take
take the podcast seriously that's that's
been happening lately the couple of
native americans get sent me some angry
tweets
remember a few weeks ago when i was
making fun of white ignorance
when i said that uh hawaii was not part
of the united states because no white
people look right out in hawaii but you
look fine in the mainland like look
leaning up against an oak tree i look
fine and i'm like i'm so sick of native
americans i'm so sick of arguing with
apaches
i literally said that like like that
wasn't enough that wasn't absurd enough
for someone to get the joke uh people
were like doing that you know like jim
norton character little uh literal gym
they would they were doing that like
well the reason why you look normal is
because you [ __ ] killed all of us
like i don't know that
like i'm somehow for that
i don't know anyways
but whatever continue to take it
seriously and actually somebody wrote me
last week i said i said fighting like a
pit bull
and somebody wrote this woman wrote
fighting like a pit bull really you
[ __ ] hard
and she went on and on and on and on and
on and i wanted to write back well like
okay i rescued a pit bull pit bulls were
bred to fight
i'm not saying it's right okay
and
lastly [ __ ] is a play on [ __ ] so
it's okay to make fun of people who are
mentally challenged but not dogs
you twisted [ __ ]
but i don't
i don't write that back because you know
what you they don't on twitter they
don't give me enough letters
uh all right the art of baking dear
billiam
dear billiam um as of late i've been
baking
i never know how to say this scones
sconces are the things that are on the
walls and the only reason why i know
that is because i had to say that one
time in an audition
scones
he said all right i'll just say scones i
don't give a [ __ ] as of lately i've been
baking scones and he writes in oh jesus
are they good
i got the idea from you and your lovely
pumpkin pumpkin loafs uh you sound so
pumped talking about your baking and it
made me want to try it it certainly adds
another dimension
uh to my game with the ladies
oh absolutely dude
let me tell you something one thing one
thing about women
all right other than the fact that they
do not support other women playing
basketball
at least they don't do it enough the
other thing about women is they like
[ __ ] sweets
okay
they love a guy that can cook if you can
actually [ __ ] make something
sugary it's great on two levels one
it makes you seem like you're gonna be a
good husband and father even if you're
not it just makes it seem that way and
they're more apt to bang you don't ask
me why i don't pretend to understand
them okay and then secondly if you
actually marry that woman
when she starts getting all [ __ ]
crampy
you know getting all [ __ ] when she
gets the cramped toast over there
what you can do is just whip up a little
pumpkin bread a little sugar okay you go
here you go honey you [ __ ] mush in
her face and then you know
she's not as irritable
it's an understandable irritability
don't get me wrong but
believe me
i know there's a lot of female comics
who say hey if you started bleeding from
your dick once a month you'd be
complaining too yeah
and if i did and you didn't you'd be
bitching about my mood so go [ __ ]
yourself
all right um so anyways he says uh
nothing twinkle toes about baking to
impress a girl yeah it is it's still
very effeminate baking is effeminate i
don't care
how you look at it there's nothing wrong
with it you're getting in touch with
your feminine side i'm so proud of you
here's another thing you can do somebody
sent me an email about this too you want
to
you want to really start slaying it if
you have no [ __ ] game
and you need to do something to make
your franchise look a little more
attractive so maybe you can make one or
two big signings during this off season
all right learn how to bake
and by all means take a [ __ ] start
taking yoga classes yoga classes are 98
women
all right
and i don't know what it is
most of them are [ __ ] hot now a lot
of granted i've taken yoga classes in
new york city in los angeles so there's
that so knock that down
by about 30 percent
um
and also a lot of them are career driven
so there's not a lot of moms in there
there's a lot of single women in there
very
limber
[ __ ] in the head women you know what
[ __ ] that scratch all that learn how to
bake no matter where you are but take
yoga in like miami take yoga classes
where there's going to be a lot of hot
women
there you go there's my stupid advice
for the week anyways let's let's
continue here he said the ladies get
turned on by a guy who can cook slash
bake because a it exemplifies our
capability to follow instructions
parentheses recipe and b they can tell
by the texture that you're good with
your hands kneading
what are you going to need her titties
[Laughter]
just [ __ ] grabbing her ass cheeks you
know
semolina
um anyways he says thanks for letting us
in on that little secret hey dude it's
all you buddy you [ __ ] took it you
ran with it
um yeah that's all that [ __ ]
i'm telling you right now if you [ __ ]
if you want to upgrade the level of ass
in your life
and you you just look at yourself in the
mirror and you're like no matter what i
do when i look at myself you know i'm
like i'm like a six a five
if you i'm telling you if you learn how
to [ __ ] bake
okay
just [ __ ] you know what you learn how to
make [ __ ] that they like to eat what's
that what's those looks like lasagna it
looks like a pie but it has eggs in it
quiche
is that what's it called
i can never [ __ ] remember the only
way i remember what that's called is i
remember the actor stacy keach
so that's the nickname for that [ __ ]
whenever i see it with nia
like we'll come walk in and i'll look at
the breakfast options and then whenever
i see it i just go stay sane
and she laughs for whatever [ __ ]
reason because she gets my sense of
humor so you've learned how to do that
here's another one
all right learn how to make red velvet
pancakes
i swear to god i'm not saying every
woman likes this but you just increased
by two percent your chances of someday
banging a model
if you know how to make red velvet
pancakes
okay some tall woman will come into your
life i'm guaranteeing it right now you
got a two percent chance more
she'll come into your life she'll eat
those red velvet pancakes okay she will
quickly go to the bathroom she will puke
them up and then jump on your dick and
you're not even gonna give a [ __ ]
okay because she's hot you know
sorry
um
that was disgusting
on so many levels anyways he says i'm
looking forward to seeing you in ottawa
hopefully you get a chance to skate
on the canal
jesus christ if that doesn't sound like
the most effeminate thing ever i'll
[ __ ] do that in a second he said
you're always welcome to come play
hockey with us after the show get the
[ __ ] out of here where
i want to play
i got two shows there i think dude [ __ ]
that if there's a game after the show in
ottawa i want in
don't [ __ ] me
because i'm gonna check my hockey [ __ ]
are you gonna be mad at me if i play i
have to play pond hockey with all my
hockey gear on because i'm in the middle
of a tour i can't crack my skull my knee
or my elbow there
um
dude come on let's do it invite me
can i come over your house if you like
the kid with no friends
oh dude that'll be a great [ __ ]
youtube video all you canadian guys out
there like no hats on street clothes
skating all around me as i'm out there
looking like robocop let's [ __ ] do it
versi not knowing how to skate sitting
there with a stogie
standing on a frozen pond i'm all over
it
all right here we go here's one from um
about one of my favorite comedians of
all time doug stanhope he said bill
heard you got you got a shout out on
doug stanhope's podcast yeah what a
great guy
i'll tell you that doug stand up you
know what
biggest heart in the [ __ ] business
he's just a great [ __ ] guy
you know what i love about stan hope
he he's one one of the best comics of
all [ __ ] time and he's still a fan of
stand up
like actually we'll sit there and enjoy
watching you say it's a [ __ ] thrill
anytime that guy he's giving me way too
many compliments uh top shelf
that's the johnny blue of compliments
right there getting that from stanhope
um
he says anytime i hear people talk about
your podcast they say it's cool that you
do it by yourself and you can somehow
keep it funny
love that you don't have guests except
it'd be cool if you have stanhope on
sometime yes i know we have to make that
happen i promise you that will happen in
fact i will text him
at the end of this podcast unless i
forget and if i forget it's not my fault
because i have add
oh man you know what i gotta use that on
my wife that'll be the funniest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever
i'm just gonna start using that as an
excuse and you know what she's gonna
laugh
because she has a great sense of humor
but
i'm gonna do it until maybe five days
after it's become already become
annoying just because those last five
days will be fun for me and i'm selfish
all right vermont
this one's talking about vermont bill i
see you're coming to vermont
[ __ ] finally no one ever comes up
here
yeah well what why would you think that
is
how about the fact you don't have a
comedy club unless it's part of a it's
like a function room in a hotel the only
time i ever performed in vermont
i performed in a comedy zone in uh
burlington
a long long time ago like literally
was it 18 yet coming up on like 18 years
ago like 18 holy [ __ ] am i old
i'm i'm getting like scary old that was
18 [ __ ] years ago
holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] yeah well you guys don't have
a comedy club there what the what do you
want from me
all you have is that beautiful land your
syrup your foliage
um it's not like i haven't come to
albany
why don't you get in a car and come down
to civilization i gotta go up there to
your [ __ ] moonshine still
and he goes he goes so how are you going
to pass the time i don't see you as
someone who fantasizes about shooting a
moose i know you're you're drinking but
vermont has what's considered
i guess you meant not drinking but
vermont is considered uh
what's considered the best beer in the
world right now it's called heady topper
holy [ __ ] bill it's good stores get
their shipment tuesday and sell out by
wednesday it's [ __ ] awesome
here's an article i'll give you guys the
link so they can sell out the same day
uh also what what are you ex what are
your experiences with vermont
um
i i love vermont i'm a new england guy i
grew up out there i go to vermont and i
think i would love to own
a house up here
i'm sorry
if i could somehow survive in this
business
um
you know
i would live in a i would live in a
place like that
i think i would go a little bit crazy
because i definitely need a little bit
of action i def i like the city
i mean i'm a suburb guy i'm not a
country guy so
um
i don't know dude that actually sounds
great if i could get a [ __ ] log cabin
i know you don't live in log cabins out
there but uh
i don't you know this [ __ ] business i
you know i'm tired man
i did a lot of road work and the more
road you do
just the more you you need a [ __ ]
vacation but once you start selling
tickets on the road you get afraid if i
take a [ __ ] week off they're going to
move on to the next guy
um
you know i actually had somebody uh
some email i was reading
and
they were complimenting my act and they
said hey bill do you ever think some
young whippersnapper's gonna come along
and pass you
and replace you uh absolutely
abso-fucking-lutely it always happens
if jordan can get too old for the nba i
can't get too old for stand-up
you know at some point no matter how
much you stay informed
you know you're going to be doing those
matinee shows with whoever's still alive
from your [ __ ] fan base
i don't mind it
um
it's supposed to happen what i'm
supposed to do
is pick up the comedy torch and run with
it as far as i can
and when i collapse i [ __ ] hold it up
like the dude trying not to spill his
white russian we got a beverage here man
um and then the next person comes along
they grab it and they run with it you
[ __ ] cheer them up tell them to take
it to the next level
and you know why that is sir because
stand up does not belong to me it's not
mine
it's an art form it's a privilege to be
able to do it make a living at it so i
try to respect that and i'll do it as
long as i can but like
you know i mean [ __ ]
it [ __ ] happens to everybody
which is why i don't have the new cell
phone it's why i drive a seven-year-old
hybrid i only have one [ __ ] tv
you hear echo echo in my [ __ ] house
because i'm i'm all my money goes to
paying this [ __ ] thing down
so uh because i know that day is going
to come that [ __ ] day is going to
come where i'm going to be sitting there
you don't want me anymore
but what about the show i did in 96 in
vermont um yeah it happens to everybody
all right i guess that's why you're
supposed to have kids someday so you can
watch them you know pass it on to them
that is one of my goals though
i never want to become some bitter
person i always want to
be
cheering on
whoever's coming next
you know that's the way you should be
you shouldn't be a [ __ ] dick about it
uh you know and then also knowing that
they're coming that drives you
like let's see how long i can keep these
[ __ ] plates spinning before they and
eventually my arms are going to get
tired and maybe don't be finished
ah jesus that's depressing but whatever
what are you gonna do all right swimming
hey billy white thighs ah [ __ ] that one
actually hurts it's [ __ ] true
[ __ ] wallpaper pace there
um you ever think about installing a lap
pool yes i have
before we bought this house i looked at
another house and they had it there i
didn't like the house but i love that i
think that that would be great
not like a lap pool you mean like the
thing where you basically
it's like long enough for you to lay
down unless you're a basketball player
and just start swimming and you're
swimming against this current
one of those ones what do you mean
literally a pool
he says anyways or maybe joining a gym
that has a pool it's a full body workout
and anytime i see old dudes swimming i
imagine they're really healthy i knew
swimmers in college and they ate and
drank like animals but they were always
really cut because they swam miles every
day i think the hardest part of getting
into the gym into a gym pool routine is
having to see other people also the
first few times when you're inevitably
tired after half a lap plus there's no
shocks in the water
um i love how you guys even write it in
the boston accent now he said so we
don't have to hear you cry about your
inner fears my interfere is getting old
and weak so i started swimming and it's
great
uh see how we brought that back around
very nice very nice
um
yeah no dude you're doing yourself a
service
you really are
uh i i am
a firm belief that you
should work out your entire life
you should always do it i mean i'm not
saying go out and play full court
basketball
i mean that in your even your 30s or 50s
just get shin splints [ __ ] up your
feet
uh i i think that you should do some
form of exercising i love swimming
i um
i i am concerned about i guess olympic
swimmers haven't died of any cancer so
the chlorine i guess isn't that bad
but that is the one thing when you jump
into a pool you're jumping into a bunch
of chemicals but i guess that's better
than jumping into uh
you know what the chemicals are killing
so we'll leave it at that
yeah
you know what you know i'm gonna look
that up right now
let's look up what one of those little
stationary lap things are
see what this is for the person who has
everything
and then i'm gonna do like the final
advertising for this [ __ ] week
all right what do we got here let's see
here
lap pool let me just look this up
oh there it is
custom lap pools what [ __ ] you
get the [ __ ] out of here this says 17
foot swim spa
is 23
hundred dollars they call it an endless
pool
are you [ __ ] kidding me
not jesus christ all this [ __ ] just
popped up when i went on this website
now now you know i'm going to get all
these [ __ ] spam emails
about endless pool [ __ ]
yeah well let's see this the 17 foot
endless pool spa features a large
exercise area that is ideal for swimming
aquatic exercise and fun
with easy access
full depth stairs and up to two jets
and with over 20 jets you can
exercise relax and enjoy increased
family time in the convenience you ever
want to piss with your whole family
let's get a lap pool
um improve your health and well-being on
an endless pool all right here's the
dimensions
17 feet
by uh well i guess now they're doing
inches 204 inches which comes out to 17
feet by 91 and a half inches
by 54
and a half inches
i guess that's how deep it is
i ain't what the [ __ ] i don't know what
i'm saying 54 it's not five feet deep is
it
what is that
four feet four and a half
i love this [ __ ] here this thing is
twenty three thousand dollars and they
have a little button here that says add
to the cart
like there's other [ __ ] that you're
gonna be getting with this
all right they have a ten foot one
oh my god
oh [ __ ] that's just you might as well
just use that place to take a dump
how much is this one
add to cart
fifteen thousand nine [ __ ] you i'll go
jump in a goddamn dirty pond
i guess it is amazing that you you're
you you're literally swimming against a
current that doesn't exist
all right now you get into some cheaper
ones here here's the [ __ ] the high
hyundai version for 10 grand
oh that thing's a joke
what is it is that a hot tub
oh go [ __ ] yourself well yeah you know i
guess i thought about it i've definitely
thought about now that i know how much
it costs
holy [ __ ] i take a [ __ ] second
mortgage out of my house to get one of
those
they are cool as [ __ ] though images for
lap pools dude why did you do this now
i'm now i'm gonna sit here look at that
one
that looks like a real pool
oh that is a real pool
who the [ __ ] lives here mock spitz
keeping fit with home lap pool
now that's now you don't give a [ __ ]
about your kids if you got one of those
you get this skinny pool that nobody can
jump into without breaking their goddamn
necks and it's for you and your [ __ ]
gray chest hair
oh whatever you guys really want to sit
here and listen to me [ __ ] reading
about lap pools
wow those things are cool as hell though
um
yeah i i thought about getting one until
i saw how much they were now that i know
how much they are i'm not
i am no longer interested i need a
friend
i need a rich friend with a [ __ ] lap
pool
good lord
just a pool in general how [ __ ] cool
is that
[ __ ] indoor pool indoor lap pool
who's this [ __ ] banker who has this
[ __ ]
indoor lap pool
you know what's funny with me i would do
i would get one of those
okay let's just say i could afford that
i'd get one of those [ __ ] things and
then
within uh
a month
i'd be bored and i would go and do
something else
i'm the worst
and i'd still owe all that money
tranquil lap pool
jesus christ you know what i'm gonna
look at these [ __ ] things
anybody out there sell lap pools
how many [ __ ] how many of these do
you sell a month
jesus christ
i'm going to get on one of those [ __ ]
home makeover shows
all right
i'm going to redo the wiring in my house
and [ __ ]
put in a lap pool
and then i'll go there and i'll [ __ ]
act oh my god a lap pool
jump around and hug everybody that
[ __ ] did it
you know
get on pimp my pool whatever the [ __ ]
the show is
all right who gives a [ __ ] all right
anyways that's the uh that's the podcast
for this week everybody
um i hope you enjoyed it
i hope you learned something i hope it
was funny even though i did it on a
sunday and if you didn't learn anything
it's not my fault because i got add over
here
um that's it that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves
and um
please watch the olympic hockey speed
skating curling and all that [ __ ] enjoy
the olympics
you know
even though the water doesn't run even
though they don't like gay people over
there god damn it these at